Tim Ferriss: Apollo.
Apollo Robbins: Yes, sir.
Tim Ferriss: So nice to have you here.
Apollo Robbins: It is a pleasure.
Tim Ferriss: And this has been
in the works for me, at least,
in my own head since I want to say 2018, 2019.
Apollo Robbins: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: And then this pesky thing that we now
call COVID came along and disrupted all sorts of
plans, but finally, here we are. So thank you for
making the trip, and I'm glad that you are here
in person, so we may get a chance to stand up.
Apollo Robbins: It's nice that it's in person
versus virtual. There's so
many more possibilities.
Tim Ferriss: So many more possibilities. Well,
let's start. So people might assume that,
right out of the gate, maybe as a fetus,
but certainly, once you entered the world,
you had the dexterity of a demigod and were
basically fated to become someone famous
for how they use their hands. Is that the case?
Apollo Robbins: No. Quite the opposite. I think
almost as opposite as it could be on that. This
is a story I've been told, that once upon a time,
my father, who was legally blind, had decided
to become a minister, went to seminary in Enid,
Oklahoma, and was walking down the streets from
seminary, but he had moved into this kind of
rough neighborhood, was trying to witness,
and these two teenagers decided to try to
steal from him. He didn't know what they were up
to, but then, when they realized he was blind,
they decided not to hustle him.
But instead, they tried to guide him
to where the bus was and encouraged him to go to
another area. And he invited them to his church,
invited them to have food on a Wednesday night,
and they came and they did. They found food and
they brought their mom one time. And then,
their mom met him and they got married,
and that's supposedly how my parents met.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Okay. So, your parents meet,
one thing leads to another.
Apollo Robbins: Yes. It's —
Tim Ferriss: I'm assuming
no immaculate conception.
Apollo Robbins: Perhaps.
Tim Ferriss: And then, you enter
the world, what were doctors expectations of you?
Apollo Robbins: They were upside down. Because
my mother had had previous children,
she had three and she was a widow,
they were also in their teens, they assumed that
I had the same father. So they didn't test their
blood. So there was a factor in the blood, I
think it was an RH factor, but it created what
they call ABO blood disease. So it required,
when I was born, that I had a transfusion.
There were a few other things. My mom had lupus,
connective tissue disease, which created tumors
in her uterus, and so my legs developed around
those, so they were twisted up. And I think,
out of that — I mean, it's an interesting —
we can go in this further, but out of that,
when I was born, there was a product of a little,
the Forrest Gump thing, that I had to wear braces
on my legs like Forrest Gump to get around.
But also, I had fine and gross motor problems,
I couldn't control my hands. It was kind of the
joke of trying to clap the hands three times at
the therapist. I was a little bit better than
that. I can clap my hands, but I couldn't do
a lot more. I had to, when I learned to write,
have a large diameter pencil that was through
a rubber ball, and I had to learn to write that
with both hands up until about the second grade.
So I had a lot of therapy, which I think that
idea of persistent learning through overcoming
an obstacle like that has helped me be resilient
with acquiring a lot of skills over my lifetime.
Tim Ferriss: Could you say more about your father?
So, was he blind for your entire life? Did that
have some onset? And how did that shape who he
was? And of course, the implicit question is how
did that affect you, but let's start with —
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — the simpler version
of the question. Could you just
tell us more about your father?
Apollo Robbins: He was a short man,
and I think that that factors in, because he was
about five foot four. So, it's pretty — quite
short. He was very physically fit. He climbed
rope without using his legs. He was very quick
to go to a fight when he was younger.
And then, one time, when he was going
into college, he was studying to be a CPA,
and he had some kind of bout that — he had
tuberculous meningitis that affected him for
about a year, year and a half. It was a very
serious disease at the time. I mean, still
is, but at the time, it was more pervasive,
and it made him blind during his productive year,
and he became kind of born again. Somebody had
come to visit him and witnessed to him during
that time, and he decided he was going to change
the course of his life, become a minister.
And that, I think, made him a very dogmatic
minister, too. He really embodied himself with
thinking about the difference of Paul versus
Saul in the Bible. And when he came out — he was
a traveling minister for most of my early life.
He would travel, visit churches. And some of the
things — I think one of the creative parts that I
really took from him was that he would travel to a
church not knowing what his presentation was going
to be, but he would find an animal along the way,
a turtle crossing the road, and that became his
presentation. He would sit it in front of the
pulpit and everybody would circle around him
and would talk about the turtle as a analogy or a
metaphor. And he was able to connect these ideas.
And meanwhile, I would sit in the back with my
little braces, and usually, a pen and paper and
try to draw everything that was going on. Art was
a big thing for me, and it had been for him before
he had lost his sight. So I think those influences
factor in later to some of the other things. But I
think one of the bigger takeaways wasn't the blind
spots he had through vision, although it did help
that when we would walk around, I would try to be
his eyes for him, there was this tug of war that
he didn't want anybody to know that he was really
blind. He didn't often emphasize that. He would
often walk with a confidence level that was —
Tim Ferriss: Ill-suited to his eyesight.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And to his
chagrin, because he would run full force into
a park bench and come tumbling over it. But
he created this ministry that was inside of
government subsidized housing and what people
think as the hood. And he would get beat up
in front of me, by gangs, sometimes, or not
necessarily gangs, but just small groups. I
guess you'd call gangs. And it was —
Tim Ferriss: Where was this
again? Can you remind me?
Apollo Robbins: It's in the — well, now,
it's branded as a TV show, the Ozarks.
Tim Ferriss: Ahh. Okay.
Apollo Robbins: But the city was Springfield,
Missouri. And he would go into those
neighborhoods. He would go, he would set
up his ministry inside of a laundromat,
and he would draw the kids in with a story. He'd
bring Kool-Aid and cookies every Sunday. He did
that for 20 years. And they would come in and he
would tell them these stories. It meant a lot to
him. He was non-denominational, but he was very
dogmatic about his specific interpretation of
scripture, which, to me, myself, jumping
ahead, I'm agnostic. I am not an atheist,
but I'm not subscribed to any religion.
But it was such an interesting learning lesson. I
think about, the difference between — most people
would judge somebody by their perceptual blind
spots of not being able to see, but sometimes,
it's worse, the stories that we tell ourselves
and how that limits our perception.
Tim Ferriss: We'll definitely
come back to this.
Apollo Robbins: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Like perception,
story, perception-shaping story,
story-shaping perception, I want to talk a lot
more about this. But since it's something you
just mentioned, the agnosticism, did you start off
religious, and then, at some point along the way,
become agnostic? Was it a response to,
perhaps, your father's dogmatism? How
did you get to self-identifying in that way?
Apollo Robbins: I started off as religious, which
I think is the same thing, people start off as
extremely patriotic to their certain country where
they're born or where you go to form a family,
where they're very religious, it'll be under that
flag as well. And my father had me study a lot
of different types of scriptures, from Jehovah's
Witness to the Mormons, because he wanted to
be able to debate those for a lot of different
topics. He had the book of Hebrew, he wanted me to
study King James for its specific interpretation.
I had a debate in debate groups for evolution
and creationism, so I was on teams that did that.
I was in a bible quiz team, where I would buzz
these buzzers and quote scriptures, and I went to
the world championships in that and placed in the
world championships. So it's all these things as
a young kid that I was deeply entrenched in that
world, and there was just poking at this thing,
that this certainty is what flagged me,
just the absoluteness of my father's answer.
And it was in juxtaposition of what was happening
on the other side of my family. So my mother,
and this shifts to the other side. It was a
dichotomy between the two, because she had been
a widow and she had raised these three kids that
— her husband had died very early, and two of them
had picked up this beyond a hobby of how they were
making money on the other side of the law, from
stealing things, running small hustles. They never
called it pickpocketing, but they would steal from
people at the zoo when they were leaning over to
watch things, animals being fed, they would cut
their pockets or steal their bags, at sporting
events through bleachers, mostly, opportunistic.
But later, it evolved. In the military, when
he came out, he started working, again like the
series, Ozark, I feel like that route that was in
Ozark is probably what my brothers are associated
with, with some type of trafficking group `—
Tim Ferriss: Drug trafficking.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, drug trafficking up
through that pipeline. One of my brothers
also did smuggling for firearms, so moving
those in and out. So it became very intense,
and I was exposed to some of that at the same
time that I was growing up with my father as a
devout minister. So it was really, I think a
fascinating juxtaposition between those two
worlds, that seeing deception in that true sense
of the word of what we often think it to be,
but yet, also, he was okay with my brothers
as people. He didn't know that that's what
they did. But I got to see both sides of that.
And they did other things publicly. They were
truck drivers or other things, and exceptional
people in many ways, but it taught me to see the
gray. I think back to your other question now,
became — when I started to go to the church,
I'd sneak out of the back of the church when
the services transition, and I'd sneak off to
another church and say, well, if the Assemblies
of God believe that tongues is the first physical,
initial sign of baptism in the Holy Spirit,
then what do the Baptists believe? And
then I'd go see their tenets.
And then, as I bounced around,
I noticed that there were just lots of little
slices of different views or perspectives,
which, to me, has continued to follow me through
my life of anytime somebody claims a truth is,
maybe we need more perspectives on this.
Tim Ferriss:
When does Ben Stone enter the picture?
Apollo Robbins: Wow, that's a great name.
Tim Ferriss: And how old are you?
Apollo Robbins: How dark do you want
to get? I can take it light or dark or gray.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe you pick, dealer's choice.
Apollo Robbins: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, we've gone dark
on this podcast before, so we can go there, but —
Apollo Robbins: I'll pop in and out. So, just as a
transition, once upon a time, I had had a pursuit
to become a syndicated cartoon artist. And I was
about 12, 13, 14, going through that. And I was
pretty confident that I could pull it off. I
wanted to be the youngest one. There was a guy who
was imitating Gary Larson's single-panel cartoons,
and I had six months of character sheets. I
was going to send them out to get syndicated.
And my parents didn't understand what this was,
or what this weird thing I was doing. They just
knew I liked to draw and do cartoons. But
I think it's important to understand the
energy of what that was. And then, there was a
fight, and parents have fights with their kids,
with their teens. It's just, mine was a little bit
more intense. My father thought I was possessed.
So they tried to evoke a demon out of me.
Tim Ferriss: Because of the cartooning?
Apollo Robbins: Not because of the cartooning,
but because of some argument that we had.
Tim Ferriss: Ah.
Apollo Robbins: But
the argument — I say this as proximity to
my large case of six months of cartoons,
my parents — some variation of a water boarding
process occurred and the water poured over on
all my art. So that's the dark side, that
it destroyed all the art. And when you had
that much work invested, it's a reset. How do you
start over? What do you do? And for me as a kid,
that was what I pictured as my escape.
Tim Ferriss: The cartooning was going
to be your escape plan?
Apollo Robbins: Yes. Yeah.
Mm-hmm. From that world. And then, I think, I
was down in our basement, I was going through
some boxes and I found this little magic gadget.
It was a piece of plastic, looked like a thumb,
and I was very curious about what that was. And
somebody said, "It's a magic trick." And I said,
"Well, how did that end up in our stuff?"
So I call a magic shop that was downtown,
and there's this guy picked up the phone
and he was probably 70 something at the
time. His name was Ben Stone. So, long
way around to answer your question.
And Ben Stone, I said, so I've got this
plastic thumb, I don't know what it is. I said,
"Do I act like my finger's cut off? What do
I do?" I'm like 14. I'm very precocious. I'm
borderline at this choice in my life, like I'm
shoplifting. I'm running away from home for two
weeks at a time living out in the woods,
sometimes. So I'm kind of at a transition
place of which way I choose as my paths in life.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's a vulnerable place where
you could have inflection points.
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: Or vectors in a
lot of different directions.
Apollo Robbins: And I had lots of ingredients to
go a certain way. Later, as I've met people in
my life, I resonated with them because of that,
because I had that fork to make a decision. So,
Ben had a big impact at that decision, and that's
why I wanted to give you the context for it.
Tim Ferriss: For sure.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And I appreciate
that. And so what happens then?
You're like, "I have this fake thumb."
Apollo Robbins: "What do I do?" Ben says,
"Come to the magic shop, downtown Springfield."
It was about 12 miles from wherever my house was.
So I rode a bike, I went with a friend,
and went down there. And he didn't show
me anything about the fake thumb, but he used
it as a trap. He made this coin move around —
Tim Ferriss: Your kind of guy.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, which is great. It's exactly
what should have happened to me. And he moved this
sleight of hand with the coin, he made it jump
around, disappeared, jumped through his clothing,
jumped through his body. I was fascinated,
because I was thinking, if this old guy can do
this, I could probably pull this off myself.
And then, he pulled out a deck of cards called
the Svengali deck, and he did a bunch of tricks
with that. He says, "So here's a choice." Kind of
like a red pill, blue pill. "This deck of cards,
you can walk out of here, and for $5, you'll be
able to do 50 tricks without even practicing,
or here's this big book and it's going to take
a lot of study. And maybe in four or five years,
you'll be able to do sleight of hand with
almost anything, but it's your choice."
And it was his way of vetting at that point, I
think. And I didn't have money either way. That
wasn't the plan. So I went back, rode my bike back
to my house, and I sold some stuff at a pawn shop,
and came back the next day and bought that
book. And for the first year, I just spent
time by myself studying the coin magic by myself.
Tim Ferriss: So I want to pause because we're
going to pick up on this particular thread. But
I want to rewind, I think, just a few years.
Apollo Robbins: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: You're around 14,
15 at this point?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So, I think this takes place
a bit earlier. You mentioned your father
and the animals that, then, become
the parable or part of the sermon.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You can't believe everything
you read on the internet, but is it true that
you also used to take in orphaned animals?
Apollo Robbins: I did.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So
can you tell me more about this?
Apollo Robbins: Wow. You have a
research department. That's great. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Got teams everywhere.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Eyes and ears on the ground.
Tim Ferriss: And so I'm curious
how that came to be, and I don't want to make
it too leading of a question, but how that has
informed, or how it reflects who you are?
Apollo Robbins: Well, it's very salient,
I think. When I was eight or so, I guess,
earlier, when I would take walks with my father,
he couldn't see things, but he would stop me when
we'd go for a hike through the woods or something,
and he'd say, "If you look around you right now,
within five foot, there's a world. There's lots
of little worlds. There's little communities of
things that are happening. You just have to find
them. So find them and tell me about them."
And that was a big thing. I saw a lizard on a
tree, and he said, "Walk straight to it and it's
going to run around the tree. When it does, reach
straight around behind it and cup your hand."
And he taught me that I could catch a lizard
by walking around the tree because it'd go to the
same position. There's kind of a pattern to that.
And he taught me this perspective taking for
animals I think helped a lot. It's a variation
of empathy that I think transferred later on for
me. But I had, at that time, squirrels, raccoons.
I babysit a bear for a weekend, a baby bear.
Tim Ferriss: Hold on. Let's take the
bear as an example.
Apollo Robbins: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: So, bear drop off, see
you next week. What exactly happens?
Apollo Robbins: How do you get a bear —
Tim Ferriss: Like how does
the bear make its way to you?
Apollo Robbins: Apparently, now, they have
a mail order service, bear in a box. Just kidding.
Tim Ferriss: Be careful on the internet, you might
get something you don't expect.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: If you try to order that.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, my address is online. So,
at that time, I had raccoons, which is a
predecessor to getting a bear, as I've learned.
Tim Ferriss: It's the bear starter kit.
Apollo Robbins: I had worked with the Humane
Society as a volunteer from eight. I was an early
entrepreneur from the time I was five. I was
always doing some kind of hustle, some job.
Tim Ferriss: Was that encouraged,
did that just emerge sort of out of
your programming out of the box? Is
this something other people were doing?
It sounds like you had a family that
was sort of active in extracurriculars. But —
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. If you run the definition
of extracurriculars, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Apollo Robbins: Well, there's a specific moment.
So, at five, I was at Walmart and I saw a toy
rifle that I really wanted. It was a single
bullet, had a little toy bullet inside of it
and I thought, I must have this. And my parents
didn't have money to buy it, but they said,
"If you want to get it, you're going to have to
come back and buy it, but write down this number."
And I wrote down the number, the cost of
what it costs to get that. And they said,
"It's probably going to be there for this amount
of time, so you've got to figure out how to get
that much money." And so I had to learn to count
that much money. So I had to learn how to count
the coins. I was finding pennies everywhere,
doing anything I could to try to get jobs
from everybody. And I got all these pennies
and nickels and dimes, and they took me, my
dad walked with me to the bank, and we got these
paper rolls and he had me put everything in there.
And as we put the paper rolls up, we'd count
up these dollar bills and other things. Walked
to the store and I brought all these paper
rolls of coins and paid for that rifle. And
it was probably about a month's work. And
after that, I thought, how can I do this
faster than going around collecting pennies? So
I was like, how else do you make money? Because
there's a lot of things in the store I want.
And so, from paper routes to creating a little art
business where — I had a knack for drawing when
I was a kid, even though I was disabled a little
bit. I was early to pick up on 2D perspective,
two-dimensional perspective or three-point
perspective. And so it gave me a unique insight,
I think, at that age, that I went back to a back
of a comic shop, took down the flyers of all the
artists there that were the best, and said, "Hey,
if I bring you work, will you — instead of giving
me a percentage, will you teach me lessons?"
And so I started mentoring and finding
mentors very young. And that has persisted
with everything I've learned since then.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. We're going to talk about
mentors. How does the bear in a box fit into this?
Apollo Robbins: Okay, back to bear in a box. Yes?
Tim Ferriss: So you get paid to babysit bears?
Apollo Robbins: No. It was a
slight ADD tangent. So —
Tim Ferriss: If so, I'm in.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, yeah,
yeah. No. It was right —
Tim Ferriss: What am I doing podcasting?
Apollo Robbins: But I was — along that,
so I was doing lots of little efforts, like I was
used to working jobs. And I went to the Humane
Society and I volunteered for a couple of
weekends to help out. And I saw a puppy get
euthanized because it didn't have enough space,
and I was like eight. And that hit me pretty hard,
because they just didn't have space.
And I was drawing a lot, and I was
really interested at that time of being
an architect. So I redrew spaces of their
cage to do triple-stacked cages, and they ended up
saying they would use the idea, so more dogs could
stay there. And they added me on to the board of
my local Humane Society when I was like eight.
Then I said, "I want to help other kind of
animals," because all these orphan animals,
I studied their habitats, and — I never have said
this stuff out loud, so it really paints a picture
of myself that I haven't seen before, but it's
fun. So then raccoons were part of it. They were
orphaned and they brought two raccoons to me,
and I raised them and reacclimated them back to
be released into the wild, and I had a knack for
that of getting animals to successfully re-release
into the wild at an early age.
Tim Ferriss: What do you
think made you good at that?
Apollo Robbins: When you can't walk the same
as everyone else, you end up watching everyone
else. And you become a people watcher, and there's
a lot of commonality between animals and people
in those ways of — you start to do a lot of what
I call perspective shifting, of jumping into their
head to think, "Why would they make that decision?
Why would they not do that?" I think that helped
with the animals because I had to figure out, "How
do I teach raccoons how to forage? How do I create
little plastic containers with mud and crawfish?"
And, "What are the things they're going to need
and why are they not adopting that?" "Why would
they..." So I was very interested in behaviors of
that at that time. So that's probably part of it.
But then this lady who was mentoring me
on that, her name was Charlie Strothkamp,
and she was a fascinating lady who'd been a law
enforcement officer that got mauled in a bar
fight where she was trying to pull some people
out of bar fight and then sliced open her arm
and she had a single arm, but she took care of
bears and buffalo and all sorts of crazy things.
She's a powerful lady. And she said, "Hey, it's
amazing what you just did with these raccoons.
Would you like to take care of this young
bear for me for the weekend? It has diapers,
and it needs to be fed." And it was magical. It
was an awesome little milestone at that time.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. How old were you?
Apollo Robbins: I was probably nine. Probably
eight to 10 is when I was doing those things.
Tim Ferriss: So it seems that, to your parents'
credit, they were open to you
having a bear in the house?
Apollo Robbins: Well, not in the house.
Tim Ferriss:
So where did the bear in the diaper stay?
Apollo Robbins: I had a habitat that I was using
for the raccoons that was square footage is large
enough to let them move and roam that I could —
Tim Ferriss: Like a shed type of place?
Or was it more of an outdoor enclosure?
Apollo Robbins: It was an outdoor enclosure that
was chained and fenced in with some options for
it to go inside that could work for it, but
I had to build a lot of those. My mom had a
background of farm, so she taught me how to
build a lot of those. I lived in the city,
but we had a strange backyard, strange house.
Tim Ferriss: So let's pick up with the book and
the path of magic. So how do you go then from
let's just say broad magic, generalist magic,
to what you have become so well known for? So,
well, first you go to med school and then you
figure out your specialty and then you do your
residency and you're like, "Okay. Actually,
I'm not really great at this, but I'm pretty good
at this. So let me zig and zag." Was it that type
of process or how did you meander your way? Maybe
it wasn't meandered, maybe it was a direct line.
Apollo Robbins: I was always full force in
whatever I did. And I think that that's part
of it, that sometimes when we're trying to get
to a place and we just feel like we need to get
to that place, we can change the vehicle. We just
know that we're on that journey, and that's often
what it was. I knew I was getting out of where
I was and that was a big thing for me is getting
out of the place where I was growing up.
Tim Ferriss: This was going to be my next
question. So at what point did you have
the conviction that magic or some variant
of magic could be your metaphorical
bus ticket out of that place in the
way that you hoped cartooning would be?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, which is a fun
combination. So the book was a dense read, and I
think it helped me though, but now when people try
to learn from magic, they try to learn it without
mentors and from YouTube videos where they don't
have to deal with people. And so you don't have to
do the perspective taking and then management of
a person in the same way that when you're first
learning it, you're just learning it to full a
camera or through a certain angle, and you only
have to do it once. So it's a different thing.
And at that time, when I was reading it from a
book, I didn't have a mentor. So I was reading
this dense copy that described how something
was supposed to look magical. I was trying to
transfer that into an idea and doing that in front
of a mirror, and I started to find ways to do it,
whether they were the way the book intended or
not. But what I had at my disposal, I think,
is also because I had been exposed to my brothers
stealing things and other things, it allowed me
to have a perspective that I didn't have the same
baseline other people did for guilty knowledge,
for an anxiety that happens when you get caught.
And so I was willing to try things that other
people thought made them shake, it made their skin
shake, make them do — and I was very comfortable
with doing a lot of unusual things with magic that
really started to shape. For instance, instead
of trying to do what you can call complete vanish
where a coin's going to disappear but rather than
retaining in your hands, you hide it somewhere
in a pocket or somewhere else. I thought,
"Why not put it on another person? They won't find
it there." And I'd had that experience. One time,
I was shoplifting early, probably 13, and —
Tim Ferriss: What were your go-to shoplifting
items? And were you shoplifting to use
them, or to resell them, or something else?
Apollo Robbins: There was a group,
you call them hobos back in the day,
but there was a group of people that lived out
behind some of the grocery stores and they knew
sometimes when I'd run away from home, I'd go stay
with them. And sometimes they would need food,
or they would need other things, or cigarettes,
or other things like that. And at one time when I
went in, I stole some cigarettes. I didn't smoke,
but I stole some cigarettes and the guy recognized
me and he came up to talk to me.
Tim Ferriss: "He's the kid who
never buys anything."
Apollo Robbins: Well,
he recognized me from, I think, my family, I
lived close by. And he came up to talk to me, and
I didn't want to be found with them. And I think
he saw me do something. So he went to check me,
and it was an interesting thing just by instinct
that I didn't put them on any pocket on me. I had
left them underneath my arm facing out the back.
So as he's checking my pockets, I reached around
behind my back with my right hand. I removed
the cigarettes from there and I load them in
his apron that was on him. So he definitely wasn't
going to look there. And I left and I got away,
but later he's going to find the cigarettes
in his apron. But I think that influenced my
style of magic too because very quickly
I would take traditional magic effects,
and things would be called an impossible location
where something disappears from myself and appears
somewhere else. I said, "Well, why doesn't it
appear on someone else? What else can I do with
that?" So I started developing a lot of that too.
Tim Ferriss: So where did you go after the book?
You have this initial tome that you're
digesting and shaping and experimenting
with. Course one. Flip the last page.
You've tested what there is to test.
Apollo Robbins: I was trying to find a magician
I had seen when I was seven, and there was a guy
that I thought he was a magician, but I didn't
realize he was a magician quite at the time. And
when I was second grade, this guy had come through
my school. And it was just an announcement from
the principal that called the teacher out of
the room, and there's this guy working on the
window. He was in overalls, and he was working
on the window and he asked one of the kids to
help measure a rope. And then he cut the rope
and it went back together. It wasn't a show,
it was just these magical things were happening
from this old guy that was fixing the window. And
then everything that came out of his toolbox that
he was trying to use was doing some weird thing,
but it wasn't a magic show. It wasn't
presented in that social contract.
And it hit me over the head. And later I found
that that plastic thumb that I found was a gift to
my parents from him. So later I went back to try
to find him and found his widow, and she told me
about this magic club that was in my hometown.
And when I showed up, they said, "Oh,
you're new to magic." And I started doing
some things and they said, "Why can you
do that?" And there's two things I could do.
I could manipulate coins, make them appear,
disappear, small objects like that. And I could
do what's called equivoque, an influence of a
series of choices that I learned early on when
I was eight from some book, but I had used it
over the years and I could do that, which is
a category of mentalism that is jazz-based.
Tim Ferriss: Did you say jazz?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. My whole
style is jazz-based, which is —
and that's an important thing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Please say more. And equivoque,
just so I understand what that means, I'm trying
to dissect the etymology, but I'm going to get
stuck in the weeds there. You are, in very subtle
ways, directing someone's choice, even though
they think they have free will and selection?
Apollo Robbins: You give the illusion of agency.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Apollo Robbins: You're allowing them to play a
game of darts, but you're painting the bullseye
on the wall after the dart has landed.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Apollo Robbins: And yet they don't realize
that they feel with conviction that that
was all choices that they made that they
navigated to. And that takes a fluidity of
thought. There's little feedback loops that
you blend in the segues and people don't
notice those and the way you use your words.
Tim Ferriss: Please correct me if this is a
lazy or inaccurate description, but for people
who don't know the term mentalism, one way
that could manifest is someone demonstrating
mind reading or something along those lines?
What is the right way to think of mentalism?
Apollo Robbins: I think there's a variety of ways,
but if you think about card magic, when you see
magician pick a card, where did that come from?
It came from at one point some card mechanics or
card sharps that cheated at cards, some of that
filtered across and made it into the entertainment
world. And there's this other category of a lot
of those from thieves and things factored into
magic. There's an interesting genealogy there,
I think. But mentalism came from psychics and
mediums. And that category was this impersonation
that I have some type of exceptional ability
to read minds, influence, predict the future,
talk to the dead, whatever it might be. The
different label is that, as a camp, mentalists
usually will not claim that they have real powers.
They'll say that they're doing it under the flag
of entertainment versus psychics and mediums who
often use the same tools will sometimes convey
that they have those God-given powers.
Tim Ferriss: Some superpowers.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Okay. So you
could do the coin manipulation.
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And you also had some mentalism game
and they were like — "Wait a second, you just said
you were new to all this. So how are you able
to do these things?" And you gave the specific
example of the equivoque. And then what happened?
Apollo Robbins: I told them I'd read these books
and I'd learned it on my own. And they were
surprised by that and they said, "Well..."
Tim Ferriss: That must've felt good.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, it was nice.
And I also learned early there that even though I
learned some things wrong by their interpretation,
it created a new thing. And they said, "Well,
that wasn't what they meant." I was like,
"Oh, that's great. So what did they mean?"
Tim Ferriss: Now, is that what you mean by
jazz-influenced? If you make a mistake,
do it twice and then it's jazz or —
Apollo Robbins: No, it's a different thing.
So if you think of a lot of performance magic,
it is very sheet music-based, very classical. It's
very structured. There's a lot of geometry and the
sight lines and the calculations of that. There's
very precise scripting of what's going on. My
style has always been very jazz-based to a fault
in many ways, but that I would feel constricted
by any script. So for me, as soon as I had an
idea, my landscape was to try it with an audience
immediately before I'd even try tested it out.
Tim Ferriss: Pick up a turtle,
walk in front of that audience, figure it out.
Apollo Robbins: Well, yeah. Jump off the cliff
and build a plane on the way down. But yes, the
turtle is a great metaphor for that. I mean, the
first time I did a show with my wife, and
initially we had this separate tension to go down,
but we were walking to go on stage and there
was a certain skill set we learned with each
other. And she said, "But what's the structure
for the show?" I said, "I don't know. I haven't
met the audience yet." And I didn't —
Tim Ferriss: And she was like, "Ahhh."
Apollo Robbins: Which is this collision of two
different mindsets, which she's changed me for the
better. At that time, I didn't want to start until
I knew — until I met the audience. It's like,
"Let's create this together," because I thought
there was a value in creating. And to me,
early on in magic, that's what I was trying to
do too because all the books said I had to do
this in phase one, then phase two, then phase
three. It's like, I get that, and that's useful
for some things, but also I want the organic
feeling that this person feels like they're
having this experience and it's not happening to
anybody else. This only happened in this moment.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So did that
magic club figure into your skill
development? Was it a launching pad?
Where did you end up going from there?
Apollo Robbins: They offered me books, more books.
Tim Ferriss: So you like books?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. And they said, "Well, if you
could get through that book that you first read,
then why don't you take these other books
and learn some of those things?" Because
there's this great quote, I don't know who
it's attributed to, but "When we buy books,
we think we're buying the time to read them."
Tim Ferriss: As my unread stack would agree.
Apollo Robbins: And I think that that's
what they were suffering from at that
time is that you have this energy, you
read my books, and teach it back to me.
Tim Ferriss: Genius.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. So they
did that to me and that was a really cool thing.
There was a couple of people that influenced my —
Tim Ferriss: It's a magic trick of its own type.
Apollo Robbins: It is, yes. But Ben was a mentor.
He wasn't with the club, but Ben did some things.
He did one thing. There was a magician I really
admired who helped me on the business side named
Mark Sparks, who was a traveling performer who
was brilliant. And I'd seen him make a coin fly up
from one hand to another, and anything I could try
to excuse or sleight of hand didn't make sense of
why that could happen. And other books I'd read,
it didn't make sense of why that could happen.
So I went back to Ben Stone in that shop,
we called Mr. E's Magic Shop. I said, "Ben, what
is with this coin?" "I don't know. I think it's
this. Here's my hypothesis one, two, three."
And he goes, "Ah. Well, that's obviously Dariel
Fitzkee." I said, "Fitzkee?" And I said, "I don't
know, that's not on my radar." And he says, "Well,
Fitzkee wrote three books. It's a trilogy.
Go read that." And so I picked up one of the
books, and it's called Magic by Misdirection
on the psychology of magic. I read it,
and it was a hard read. And I came back and I
said, "Ben, it wasn't in there." And he says,
"Well, he wrote two other books, The Trick Brain
and Showmanship for Magicians." So I read all
those. I came back and I said, "It wasn't in
any of those." He goes, "I must be wrong."
And Ben tricked me again. He tricked me to
use my desire to learn how to make that coin
fly up to read three books that have influenced
me to this day of a very structured, analytical
approach for performance that I needed, but also
for the psychology of magic and understanding how
an illusion is constructed in the audience's mind.
And I needed that at 15 because I wasn't thinking
about that. So that was the biggest thing, I would
say. And there was many other people that — from
that time period, a gentleman named Ed Dillard,
who was a year-round Santa Claus who did amazing
things. He would go into a mall and he created
experiences. That was a great thing because —
Tim Ferriss: He was a year-round Santa Claus?
Apollo Robbins: Yes, he lived it all year. So
anybody who saw him — but when you'd see him in
a mall — you see people go up and a kid sits on
Santa Claus. But what would be effective with him
is a 12-year old would say "Hi," at Santa Claus,
and he says, "It's good to see you, Nick. So
what's been happening this year, Nick? It sounds
like you've had some problems with your friend.
We want to talk about it." And he would say these
things and just know so much about someone. And
he was mentalist as well. And not to also throw
off that he had an inner ear microphone in his
ear and the parents had the other side of it,
but he had this great book of Latin that was
Santa's book, and it was all carved out of
leather with this beautiful book, and he would
tell anybody about anything about themselves
but through the auspices of Santa Claus.
And I just loved this beautiful approach
that it wasn't so much of what I saw magicians
initially getting in a magic for was to fill a
hole in themselves. They were hiding behind
what they're doing, they're trying to get
this validation from somewhere, and they needed
attention. And that wasn't the driver for me. I
was trying to figure out, "Is there something here
I can create sparks in people, an experience like
that guy did in my second grade when it came in
as repairing the window or the Santa Claus?" So
I think it started to shape that I had one skill
set, which, outside of magic, I could steal
things that I could blend in. And there was a few
factors also. I stage a little bit martial arts,
I had some understanding of animation.
And all of them kind of settled together
to create a style that I developed in that shape.
Tim Ferriss: Is the animation and form the style?
Apollo Robbins: Animation, there was a
great book called The Illusion of Life
by Disney's — what do you call them? His nine
men. But it talks about the illusion of life,
in just frame by frame when you're hand drawing,
how to create life motion. And one of those is
secondary actions and what they call slowing in
and slowing out, something moving at the top of a
curve, how it will have more frames versus on the
bottom of a curve. And I started realizing there's
overlaps in relationships of that to Aikido. And
when you study Aikido, there are certain half
moves and half circles. And so when I started
blending those together with sleight of hand,
I realized that I could lock people in a
dance. When you're doing a cross body lead,
how does somebody know that you have a lead and
how do you transfer that with your hands? So by
putting those together, I started to see that I
could manipulate a person's body and tell them a
story that they wouldn't register consciously, and
I could lock up their body without them knowing
that I had locked up the mechanics.
Tim Ferriss: Lock up,
meaning like gain control, hijack?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. Put them in a frame,
as you would say, on the street. So I could put
them in a frame that I didn't need other people,
a team of thieves to help me. I could do it by
myself and I could use certain things that would
draw. I noticed from animation because of that,
there were certain motions that drew attention,
and that later became a thing, too.
Tim Ferriss: So a lot of people try
magic in some form or another. Very few people
make it to the point where they are performing,
giving TED talks, getting profiled by The New
Yorker, et cetera. Very few. What were some of the
most important inflection points, say, picking up
where we left off and after reading these books,
after having these various inputs, I guess maybe
it could have been during these various inputs
like the martial arts and the jazz and the dance
and so on. What were some of the critical moments,
let's say? Could be decisions, could
be interactions, could be people you
meet that helped to set their trajectory.
Apollo Robbins: I'm so fortunate to have
had some incredible people influence me along the
way, and I've surfed through my career from person
to person that's made an impact on me. But back
at that time, there's one I'd say that makes the
most impact, which is my wife. I'll circle back
to her because she's probably the biggest. But at
that time, when I was in Las Vegas, I was married
when I was young. And so it was my first wife.
Tim Ferriss: When did you first get married?
Apollo Robbins: I was 18. So I was married.
I had a son. Now I have two kids. I have a son
who's 30 and a daughter who's six. So fascinating,
two different worlds. But at that time, I
had to provide for my family. So it amped
up that entrepreneurship that I think made it
a very serious thing that I had to find out if
I'm going to do this — I was in a juxtaposition
between two worlds. I had given up art because of
this incident with my father, but in school and
high school, I had some teachers recognize that
I shouldn't, and they pushed me toward design
and illustration and computer graphics. And I
had two careers that I could do simultaneously,
the design aspect of that, and then moonlighting
with the magic style and comedy clubs and
things. So I was doing both of those in
high school. But then I was transitioning into
doing that full-time by the time both of those
simultaneously as I graduated high school.
And there was a gentleman who was a touring
magician from Las Vegas, came through
town and he saw me performing and he said,
"You should go to Vegas." And I said, "Yeah,
that's what everybody says." And he says,
"Come visit me." I said, "I've never flown on a
plane before. I don't even know what it's like
outside of Missouri." And he says, "Come."
And I flew to Vegas to visit this guy. His
name was Daryl Martinez. They called him The
Magician's Magician. And he picked me up at
the airport. He drove me straight downtown into a
gambling spot. And he was a gambler. He showed me
that world and he said, "Vegas has everything to
offer, but it will give you nothing." Which was
perfect for me because I love working for it.
And I formed a model real quick. I looked at
all the magicians that were around me, and I
recognized that they blew me away. They had
exceptional skills, things I didn't know were
possible, but they didn't have everything. They
either had high skill, which I put underneath
the talent. They had low business sense maybe
or their ambition to take that effort to the
next place. And the combination of those were
atrophied in different areas. And I felt like
even if I don't have the same skill level, I can
bring some of that back or find other angles.
And so I decided to move out to Las Vegas and
to try to go after that. I'm jumping through a
timeline real quick, but I was initially working
at doing a couple of design jobs. And my second
one was for a series of slot machine design,
designing the animation sequences for slot
machines and doing all the illustrations for that.
And I was doing freelance artwork for a hypnotist
named Justin Tranz. And I was designing all this
stuff and he said, "Why are you here?" He says,
"For a couple years you've been in this little
place. You're doing freelance artwork for me." He
said, "But your performing capability," he says,
"you could just do something else." And I
said, "What's a good reason? Give me one
good reason." He says, "Wouldn't it be amazing
story sometime later in your life if people said,
'Why did you quit your job as an artist and
become a magician or performer full time?' And
it was because a hypnotist told you during
a lunch break." I thought that was a great
idea. So I went back into my job and I gave
my notice that day. And that was a Friday.
Tim Ferriss: Wow, what a gift. Well, it depends on
how that's — I mean, I know you're sitting here,
so I'm not sure the intervening experiences
looked like, but it seems like a gift.
Apollo Robbins: That was a big point because
that was a jumping point. And it had a context
in that I was a senior designer at that
time in the company I was working for,
and the reason why I didn't say their name, they
had led off a large production team that supported
the graphics I did. I'd hand my designs to them,
they would port them across to bigger things.
Tim Ferriss: They'd let them go.
Apollo Robbins: They found a way
to get around their contract. So they'd
outsource them to another company and
then let that company fire them.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so they wouldn't
owe any severance or they'd dodge something?
Apollo Robbins: Yes, they'd dodge all their
severance. And that made an impact on me. So they
had just given me a bonus. They'd just given me a
raise. That was the context at that time that
he said that, "Well, why are you here?" And
it wasn't about the money for me. And it was that
moment of, "Yeah, what would happen if I did this
thing? I don't know how, but let me just clean
this slate on this thing and see what happens."
And coincidences, I still believe, happened.
And that weekend, a friend of mine said, "Hey,
I'm going on tour for a couple of weeks and
there's a show called Caesars Magical Empire,
and I was wondering if you could come fill me
in. Fill in for me that for those two weeks,
starting on Tuesday." I said, "Perfect timing.
That sounds great. I'll give that a shot."
Tim Ferriss: What did you have ready
at that point? Filling in, does that
mean you have a 30-minute set, a 15-minute
set? I'm not sure if set is the right term,
60-minute set? I think of comedians working
on standup material and to get a polished hour
could take years for something, right?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: So what did you have when
this opportunity falls from the sky? "Hey,
could you fill in within the next week?"
Apollo Robbins: I'd been doing it professionally
at the same time. So even back in my hometown,
I had contracts with — I did restaurants, I did
nightclubs. I had 15 different contracts per week.
Tim Ferriss: So you had things you knew had
already worked so you knew that
you could string them together.
Apollo Robbins: And I knew I could make
an impact. And the big skill I had that
was unique when I came to Vegas, I decided,
"Let's just drop the other stuff and just
focus on the stealing." Because at that point,
there was one other guy who was really good, two
other guys that were in that space. One
of them had passed away. He was a friend,
and he worked at that place. So it was a good
angle for me to explore further in more depth.
Tim Ferriss: To differentiate yourself.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, as a brand.
I'll give you — just paint a picture of the —
it's a fascinating thing. My first show I ever
did in Las Vegas, separate from Caesars, it was
just a corporate event for a large corporation,
and it was a red carpet event. They had
limousines pulling in. It was very different
for a Missouri boy, when I first moved out
there. And these agents, they said, "So,
all right, go steal things from people,"
I guess. And they gave me hundred-dollar
poker chips to give to people as gifts. And
I went up to this guy, and the agent was
watching. And the first time I tried to steal —
Tim Ferriss: When you say agent,
this is someone who works at the casino?
Apollo Robbins: These are agents that hire
for entertainment in Las Vegas.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Apollo Robbins: And they were
watching and they were trying to
vet if I was a good fit. And the first guy —
Tim Ferriss: This is like your audition gig.
Apollo Robbins: It was kind of, yeah, if they're
going to hire me back again. And so I walk up to
somebody that was important. They brought
this big VIP up to me right away. And as I
go to steal his watch, his watchband was very
worn out. And it snapped in two pieces while
I was stealing it. And I could feel my ears
turning red. And I just was running through
the gamut. "Do I give this back to him?
Which is more important?" Because I got a
lot of pressure at that moment. And so I was
performing with him and another gentleman,
and then I said, "Oh, and here's your watch."
And he's shocked that I have his watch. And
before he even processed, I pulled out the
other piece of his watch and gave him the
second piece of it, which was a leather band.
And I said, "See that lady over there?" He goes,
"That lady?" I said, "Yeah. See her watch?"
I said," I'm going to let you just see it a
second time. This time I'm going to steal her
watch, and I'm going to try to do it without
breaking it." Now that's a lot harder, but I'm
going to try to see if it's possible." He goes,
"No, you can't do that." And I was gambling
on the idea that he didn't need the money. He
probably knew that he needed to replace this band,
but I'm reframing it that, "Hey, that's a whole
another level. You guys want to try it? And let's
move past this idea that I just broke his watch."
Tim Ferriss: Yes. Hard to script for.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. And that's
constantly what was required from me.
Tim Ferriss: "I didn't take cigarettes.
You took cigarettes in the apron."
Apollo Robbins: Yes. So my career
has been majority of those, right? And when my
first day after I had left my job as a designer,
I come over to work at Caesars Palace. I was
accused of stealing this lady's rings. I was
doing a performance in front of a group. And
she said, "My rings!" And her husband said,
"Where'd they go?" And she says, "Somebody stole
them." I hadn't even touched her. And I said,
"What did you have?" And she goes, "I
had diamonds and rubies and emeralds (oh,
my)!" And I just said, "Oh, I must've sent them as
a child support payment." I just turned it in as a
joke. And then the husband really got mad.
Tim Ferriss: Didn't like it.
Apollo Robbins: No. And so once everybody cleared
out, they came at me, come up to me, came at me
too. And he said, "Give us the rings." I said,
"Do you really believe that I have your rings,
or are you joking?" And he says, "No, give us the
rings." And he says, "We're going to the police."
And they started to leave. And I said, "Stop.
Don't walk away." And he goes, "What?" I said,
"If you walk away right now, you'll never know
if I have your rings because I could hide them
anywhere. But I want you to know that I don't.
So I'm going to walk in front of you and I'm
going to keep my hands out to the side. You watch
me, we're going to walk to the police together."
So we walked out in the casino, we went to
security, and I got strip searched. And his
wife went up. She was very dramatic, which to me
conveyed that she was sincere about her belief,
that she really believed that that happened. So
then she up in her room found her ring sitting on
a sink as she'd been washing her hands.
Tim Ferriss: Did you get an apology?
Apollo Robbins: I did.
Tim Ferriss: That's good.
Apollo Robbins: But I think it may also helped.
It wasn't just an apology. It helped me secure
a job there beyond filling in for a friend.
I got it for five years. So that five years
came from how I handled that situation. And
over that time, I had people grab my throat,
pull out a gun one time, pull out knives. I had —
Tim Ferriss: Hold on a second. This is at shows,
right after a show. Did it happen —
Apollo Robbins: During shows all over
the place. I've had every variation
of that happen. And that's —
Tim Ferriss: Because they think you have stolen
something or they're upset that you duped them?
Apollo Robbins: Or maybe I have, yes. But it
was in a social context of entertainment, right?
Tim Ferriss: Right, right.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. But still,
that's a different thing than if you mess up on
a magic trick. If you mess up on a magic trick,
they caught you, "Look, I understand how your
trick works." In the space I was playing,
it was accusations, law enforcement, lawsuits,
and I was constantly doing with that. I learned
certain rules. Don't steal from someone who's
been drinking. Don't steal from someone who has
Alzheimer's or any potential for that because
that's a really hard one to fight your way
out of if they believe they had something they
didn't. And I started making my own set of rules,
and it changed one big thing in my style, which
was, all right, I'm going to treat this like a
vampire. I'm going to tell them —
Tim Ferriss: Like a vampire.
Apollo Robbins: Vampires had to be introduced
into the household, across the threshold.
Tim Ferriss: You're right,
they need to be invited.
Apollo Robbins: So I'd say, "In three
minutes I'm going to be wearing your watch,
try to catch me." And if they say "Yes," but
that was the first time I had ever seen that
happen. When I had studied the history of
theatrical pickpocketing and everything,
there wasn't that open challenge that, "Beware,
this is about to happen. If you engage, that's
the game we're going to play. Are you ready?"
But it now meant a whole different thing,
but it came from all those concerns and lawsuits
and everything, I'll say, that almost happened.
Never landed. But now I developed this style that
was a very different style, very potent style,
but instead of surprise, it was suspense.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, exactly. It was suspense.
It was also a preemptive strategy.
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Right. So you would have
less need to be good at reacting.
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Because you're
setting the ground rules and getting
invited as a vampire. At what point then,
you said five years, is it within that span that
Jimmy Carter and the Secret Service show up?
Apollo Robbins: Yes. So at that time, I had been
there — and I'll give you more context. So when
I was performing, it was a specific role at the
beginning of the show. 24 people would go into
a certain area and they'd be there for 10 minutes
before they went on to the next part of the show.
During that time, I would steal from four people
and pass their items off for the function in the
show. And one person then I would bring up front,
steal all of his stuff while everybody's watching
and give it back. And then later everybody
would find it and it comes back to them later.
I would do that every 10 minutes, six times an
hour, five hours a night, five nights a week,
for five years. So some math, is somewhere around
200,000 people, plus my side gigs, that it became
a lab for me to experiment. Can I take someone's
glasses while they're wearing them? And what does
that do? Is it possible? Can I steal their belt?
What are the boundaries? And that was a place for
me to experiment on the aspect of that.
Tim Ferriss: So could you please
tell the story of the Secret Service?
Apollo Robbins: So about probably near the end,
about three years after I'd been performing at
Caesars Palace, there was a special night when
I had come into work and they had a big meeting
before the show. And the manager said, "We have
a previous president of the United States coming
in to visit and we are going to have some people
go home that haven't had background checks…"
Tim Ferriss: Slightly different rules.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. Because they'd done
background checks on all of us. And he said,
"There'll be photo ops as he goes through the
show. He's got a small party with him. But the
whole theater is just going to be sectioned off
for that. They have Secret Service will be here,
so don't be alarmed, but they'll be stationed
throughout the casino and throughout the theater."
And then we were all departing and he said, "But
Apollo, they asked you not to meet the president,
not to shake his hand, they don't want it to get
in the news if you were to steal from him." And
everybody just kind of laughed. And I went back to
him and said, "Well, that's not fair, I'd like a
picture with the president." It was Jimmy Carter
at that time. Not that I was in the era of Jimmy
Carter, he was an ex-president at that time.
He was on a book tour. And he said, "But they
didn't say anything about the Secret Service." I
said, "What does that mean?" They didn't say that
you couldn't steal from the Secret Service.
Tim Ferriss: You didn't hear this from me.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. "But do you think you
could?" And I'm so happy that he posited that
then versus now, because I'm in my twenties, I
probably wouldn't do those things now in the same
way. I mean, I still steal from Secret Service
today, but it's a different context, usually.
Tim Ferriss: Wait a minute,
we'll come back to that.
Apollo Robbins: There you go, get back to that.
Tim Ferriss: All those Secret Service
bar mitzvahs that you go to.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, it's a thing.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. All right.
Apollo Robbins: Why else move to Washington, DC?
Tim Ferriss: Yes. Okay. So you wouldn't do it
exactly the same way. And then what unfolds? So
you get this side chat, which is like —
Apollo Robbins: I get a side chat.
Tim Ferriss: Technically they
didn't say you couldn't do
something with the Secret Service. And then what?
Apollo Robbins: He brings in the head of security
for Caesars Palace, they talk to me about certain
provisions and warnings. Don't take any of their
firearms, don't touch them, that would still
be considered a felony. If they do take you to
the ground, it's on your own, you're on your
own for this. We have plausible deniability.
Tim Ferriss: We disavow all knowledge.
Apollo Robbins: Yes. And that this could
be rather serious, which I thought was
a really interesting challenge. And so
I moved into that. It was approaching the show
and as I was moving through, I saw two of them
were stationed at a certain point. And I went
up and started to hit those guys. And I see,
it was the way I approached them, I got in
their space and I stole several of their items.
Tim Ferriss: So there are two Secret Service
agents, I guess, is the right term, maybe?
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And to a lay person,
to a civilian, I think two more complicated,
but maybe two actually provides more surface
area/opportunity. But when you say you went into
their space, could you paint a more detailed
picture of how you ended up taking items from
two very well-trained people who have a lot
of situational awareness, who know what you do?
Apollo Robbins: Sure. You used a great word there,
you said surface area. And surface area,
they have a lot to protect on themselves,
both where they keep their firearms, their
credentials, the keys, the itinerary,
all these things. So they just treat it as a
whole, but it's got all these little parts.
And I like to think of attention as a
limited resource. It's really useful
to think of the economics of attention. If they
spend their attention one place versus another,
how do you toggle that? And it's not
traditionally like, look here and not there,
you're curating their attention. So in that
there's ways to approach it. And it's usually
contextual. It changes from person to person.
And when I approached them, I hadn't had any
experience with anyone like that before. And
the context was different. They knew who I was
specifically when I walked up. There's a nickname
for me in the show, they called me Klepto. They
said, "It's not happening," was I think the
first thing I heard from them. And they said,
"No, it shouldn't at all." I said, "'Yet' I
think is the word you're looking for, right?"
So I kind of pushed at the boundaries of their
confidence level, because I was coming in pretty
confident. And one of them stepped back
as I approached. And there's a way that I
approach that gains access to someone's space.
If you think of someone's personal space as a
bubble and their proprioception of how you
get into their awareness of their space,
it's kind of shaped like an egg. And it's larger
up front, it's narrow on the sides, and it's
shallow on the back. And you can break eye contact
with someone to sneak underneath that as you move
through. I can show you more of that later.
But as you gain access, there's a way of
approaching from the side that can often help.
So when I started to sidle up next to one of the
gentlemen to show him something, he stepped back.
And they have a term for it called maintaining
occupied space. And it also indicated to me with
a slight brush that in my world I have to know
a lot of being able to determine what's inside
people's pockets and the printing of a jacket,
what it means, being able to make pretty good
estimates of what a good target is inside of
the outline of a pocket. So as soon as he
stepped back on the left, he indicated to
me that he might have a firearm on that side
versus on his right side. So it was probably
underneath, in a holster underneath his jacket.
And so I just acknowledged that, I put that on
the surface. I said, "You're very well-trained." I
said, "It's going to be much harder to do anything
with you." I said, "You've been doing this for
a while?" And he says, "Yes, I've been doing
this for a while." And I said, "Okay, so I'm
going to have to do it to you, sir." And so I
lean into the next guy. And the next guy's like,
"That's not happening." And he was very serious.
But now as I'm facing him, and this other
gentleman is here, he doesn't realize that
he's given me access from the side.
Tim Ferriss: The first guy?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, the first guy.
Tim Ferriss: He thinks he's off the clock.
Apollo Robbins: He thinks he's off the
clock. And so just by — that's one of
the things that by setting that expectation,
he thinks he's done and the play has moved
on. But now I reached underneath my arm,
and I steal from inside his jacket. And I
steal what I found to be his credentials, it was
wallet, passport shaped, and I steal his glasses
from his outside pocket and I steal a couple of
things. And as I was talking to the other guy —
Tim Ferriss: As you're doing
that, does the other guy notice?
Apollo Robbins: No, he doesn't notice. And he
can't see because he's watching my hands. And
they're trained to watch hands. But there's
all these pause points I learned over the
years from different thieves and other ones of
holding out places. And if I steal something,
you're not going to get to see it go
in and out of my pocket or anything,
it's going to go somewhere else. So I can put it
on them in a more accessible spot or I can put
it on me at another place. So I did some of that.
But at the end of that, with the two guys, I said,
"I didn't get anything except for this. I don't
really know what it is." And I pull out this paper
that was kind of tri-folded. And as I'm opening
it up, I see what it is, it's now the itinerary
where they're taking Carter to. And I said, "I
can't really read it with these glasses on."
He realizes that I'm wearing his glasses that
were in his pocket. And he goes, "Hey." And he
takes my glasses and he looks at the paper and he
says, "Hey." And he snatches it away. I said, "And
I really don't think you should read that without
the proper ID." And then he reaches in his pocket
and he realizes he doesn't have the credentials.
And the other guy's laughing very hard at him.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sure.
Apollo Robbins: And he said,
"I'm not going to be the only one."
Tim Ferriss: "Ooh, Dad's not going
to be happy with that when he finds out."
Apollo Robbins: And so he says, "You're going to
do this to the other guys." So he got on his mic
and he starts telling me to go to the other teams.
So I now have an advocate and an in to approach
the other teams because this guy's sending me
because he didn't want to be the only one.
But that's kind of why I was mentioning about
the jazz. I mean, I didn't know, I've never
stolen with somebody with a presidential
itinerary and credentials and glasses in that
combo before. But I have to ad lib with what I
find and how I give it back. And it is a unique
thing that he knows is the only time I'd done
that is with him until I did it to the other guys.
Tim Ferriss: So what was the significance, if any,
of that whole evening to you or your career?
Maybe it was indirect in the sense that it
increased your confidence, that enabled you to
do X, Y, and Z. But if there was significance,
what was the significance?
Apollo Robbins: I think "legend"
is too strong of a word. But there are things —
Tim Ferriss: Nothing travels like a good story.
Apollo Robbins: It does. It gives people a
story to tell. And it did. And it was one of
a handful of legends or lore, I guess, lore is
a better thing, that traveled beyond me. And I
found that lore can take you so fast so far,
but also it can encapsulate what people think
you are versus what you are. And it can be hard to
underpromise and overdeliver when people have this
expectation of what you can do.
Tim Ferriss: For sure.
Apollo Robbins: Because it spread into, "Oh, you
stole their bullets and you took out the bullets
out of their guns." And I've heard all sorts
of variations of that. That I began working
for the government from that day forward.
Tim Ferriss: "William Wallace, 12 feet tall.
He shoots flaming lightning out of his arse."
Apollo Robbins: It was much better when people
underestimated me because working against over
confidence was a great way to play. But at that —
Tim Ferriss: Pros and cons, right?
Apollo Robbins: Pros and cons, yes. And I
was asked to speak for the Secret Service. It was
around a time where there was a shooting at the
Pentagon and there were two officers outside and
a gentleman had approached and he drew firearms
and both of them missed it, even though they
thought they were watching for his hands. But
they were both tasked on a similar thing.
There's an interesting thing in psychology
called inattentional blindness. Dan Simons
and Chris Chabris was his partner. They did
a book called Invisible Gorilla where
you watch a basketball being passed —
Tim Ferriss: An incredible video.
Apollo Robbins: And I like to refer
to that as task blindness. I think it's a more
approachable term. But when someone is tasked,
they often miss other things. And at that time
I was asked to come speak to the Secret Service
afterwards. So I was like, I'm not being arrested,
I guess this is a good thing, but now I'm
traveling to DC and I'm going talk to the Secret
Service. And I was asked about that, about task
blindness and inattentional blindness.
And this overlapped into two fascinating
neuroscientists that I met, Stephen Macknik and
Susana Martinez-Conde. And they had been studying
magic and visual illusions, but they were also
very interested in cognitive illusions. And in
that space they wanted to see what could be done
with attention. And they approached me and said,
"Can we do an experiment? Do you have any
ideas?" And at first it was like a little session
where they had different magicians that were
legends, Penn and Teller, specifically Teller,
talking about theories. And they were saying, "Is
there anything there to pull research out of?"
And I posited that I think we only have two
sight lines. And this circles back to my early
days with animation. And I said, "I've noticed
when I'm stealing that if I move in a straight
line that there's a transition point from A
to B, that when something is no longer at A,
that people expect to be there, they bounce back,
their attention bounces back like a rubber band
to B. But if I move in a half circle from A
to B, when we get to that destination point,
nobody ever looks back at the point of origin."
I said, "So I sense that there's two types of
sight lines and there's a kind of suppression
that happens during those. And I think that
that's an interesting place to experiment with."
And they said, "Yes it is. We could do that with
eye tracking software." And we did. And it turned
out to be right. And that was the change, that was
the flip of a switch because then I — it was part
of a paper that they published in Nature Journal.
And then I was asked to speak at the International
Society for Neuroscience, 10,000 neuroscientists.
Tim Ferriss: It broadened your lane.
Apollo Robbins: It did.
Tim Ferriss: Or you gained more lanes.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. And when it realized that it
wasn't just me stealing, but that that same
concept of psychotic versus smooth pursuit
eye movements and their impact on different
things started to branch out in other areas.
And then I was asked to speak on attention and the
current models of attention at MIT and Harvard and
other ones. So it all changed right there.
Tim Ferriss: How did you connect with the
scientists? Just so I can connect the
lore, the stealing bullets from midair
with the Secret Service, to connecting on the
scientific side, how was that connection made?
Apollo Robbins: Teller from Penn and Teller.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that was Teller.
Apollo Robbins: It was Teller. Teller said he
was approached about this. And at that time,
him and I had become pretty good friends
and we spent a lot of time together. Penn
was also a friend. Teller was interested in
the research side of it on the backside. And
he asked me to come join at that effort.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Okay. I want to pick
up a couple of micro gingerbread topics that
I've let alone, that I've committed to myself
I would return to. So the first is, in terms of
making the coin levitate into the other hand,
did you ever figure that out?
Apollo Robbins: I did.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. And I don't know —
Apollo Robbins: A lot of blood,
sweat, and calluses, but yes.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. I think that gives
me the answer that I'm looking for. Because
we have a mutual friend, Simon Coronel. And
I don't want to speak out of school, so
I'm not going to get into the how of it,
I suppose, but I've seen him do this. And rest
assured it is so much harder than people think.
Apollo Robbins: It is. It's something that your
body wasn't trained to do, you've never had a use
for that. And to train it to be able to do that,
to make something animate, is a combination of
unusual muscles that people wouldn't usually use.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it is so much harder than
people can possibly imagine. Which makes me
think of, speaking of Teller, a presentation
that he gave, I think it was at the
Entertainment Gathering, and he said,
"I'm going to show you a video," and I think
there was a balloon involved, or a ball.
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And he shows the magic trick,
let's call it the performance on video. He says,
"All right, now I'm going to explain how I did
it." And he explains it. And then he shows it
again and he says, "Now are you more or less
impressed?" I'm paraphrasing here tremendously.
Apollo Robbins: But it was a love story,
right? It turns into a love story with an effect.
That's what I thought was the greater lesson of
him showing it and exposing it was this beautiful
piece of him coming and spending time with this
effect and giving part of his life to it.
Tim Ferriss: The second thing I wanted to
ask about, you have thousands, tens of thousands
of repetitions because you're doing four people
every, what was it, 20 minutes, 10 minutes?
Apollo Robbins: 10 minutes, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Multiple times an hour, over and
over and over again. So you're getting a lot of
reps. What do you do when it doesn't work? What's
your recovery or how do you handle that? Because
I can't imagine, as you're experimenting, you
must push the envelope, and I imagine, I mean,
with any skill, it's not going to be a hundred
percent hit rate. So what do you do? Even at
let's say for instance the Magic Castle, it's
like you see how people recover when things
don't work out exactly as planned.
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: For me, that's part of
the art. I mean, it's fascinating.
So what do you do in those circumstances?
Apollo Robbins: I think there's a subtext
to what you're asking that is unique to the
way that the context in which I steal. In
that I have a different social contract
with my audience than a thief does on the
street. So because I can talk to someone,
I get a different access to their body,
I can justify what I'm doing more like — it
functions more like sparring in martial arts,
that if they start to pick up on a thing, there's
a feedback loop that I can see. And the cost of
them fixating on that catch comes at the cost
of them losing something else. So as soon as
they start to detect one thing —
Tim Ferriss: Right, if they
cover their head, you go to the body.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. And once they catch
that one thing, they might find themselves three
pounds lighter in other places because they've
lost all these other things. But there is a very
real — so it changes the definition of fail. Is
fail getting caught stealing a watch or a belt
or glasses? I was pretty good at rolling with
that and improvising with those things. And
realizing that if they started to catch that,
I could turn it into another situation.
And I would load strange things on people.
Like I loaded a bag of oregano on a grandma and I
said, "What's this for, Grandma?" And it's like —
Tim Ferriss: Hold on. This is actually the
perfect place for me to just read an excerpt
profile of you, which was by Adam Green
in The New Yorker. And the title of this,
I recommend everybody read this, and if you have
anything you'd like to correct in the piece,
we can cover that too, but “A Pickpocket's Tale:
The Spectacular Thefts of Apollo Robbins.” So this
is one of my favorite paragraphs —
Apollo Robbins: Fairy tales, yes.
Tim Ferriss: "When Robbins hits his stride,
it starts to seem as if the only possible
explanation is an ability to start and stop time.
At the Rio, a man’s cell phone disappeared from
his jacket and was replaced by a piece of
fried chicken; the cigarettes from a pack
in one man’s breast pocket materialized loose in
the side pocket of another; a woman’s engagement
ring vanished and reappeared attached to a key
ring in her husband’s pants; a man’s driver’s
license disappeared from his wallet and turned up
inside a sealed bag of M&M’s in his wife’s purse."
Okay. So hard for me to even make any sense
of half of that. But you're loading things
on people is where you were.
Apollo Robbins: I am. Yeah. I
take things off, I switch them, I alter them.
Tim Ferriss: So you're creating for yourself
options also, right?
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: It's not like
you have one trick you're
executing and if you flub it, the trick is done?
Apollo Robbins: No. Yeah. That's why I [inaudible
01:26:51] sheet music versus jazz. They don't know
where I'm going, so we can always change the path.
And in fact, when I used to work in situations
where I would just walk around with a group,
which I miss, because I don't really get
to do that, I'm mostly a keynote speaker
now. But I used to do a lot of corporate type of
events where I would move through a crowd and I
would walk up to the guys and say, "So guys, you
know why I'm here, right? I'm supposed to steal
everything you have." And so I'd just say that up
front. It stops most conversations. And I'd say,
"You got anything on you?" And you just see
them check, they would just bump their wallet
or that sort of thing, and I'm just clocking.
It's like, "Okay, so I've got the keys here…"
Tim Ferriss: You know exactly —
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, so I'm making a mental map,
and now I'm about to move into the circle —
Tim Ferriss: They telegraphed all of
their possessions.
Apollo Robbins: Yes,
because they don't believe it's true. They just
— we're having a conversation. And now I'm making
that effect. It's like, okay, that seems
to be a room key here, that's over here,
this is what here. And as I move through them
— in real pickpocketing, they call it fanning.
Small movements with my elbow or my hand can
give me an idea of what things are in a breast
pocket or other things. And I can now —
Tim Ferriss: It's like a shark taking
little nibbling bites, feeling things out.
Apollo Robbins: Yes. And just taking inventory,
you could say. Yeah. And now I'm crafting, okay —
Tim Ferriss: Or a feeling out round in boxing,
same thing, right?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Where people are gauging
distance, they're seeing how people react.
Apollo Robbins: What's their
pattern, what's their go to?
Tim Ferriss: What are their defenses?
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: What are their vulnerabilities, yeah.
Apollo Robbins: Which is interesting because now
that I don't have that, I've gone back to martial
arts, because it was one of the few places I could
get that feeling. And I was studying a Filipino
style of martial arts, and as I was new in it, one
of the things that I could do in the first part
was they would go to draw a secondary weapons,
sometimes like a trainer blade, and it wouldn't
be there. You can't do that trick a lot. But
it's a great trick when they go to draw and then
it's not there. They're very surprised. And now —
Tim Ferriss: I'm sure they're very surprised. All
right. So following this gingerbread trail, I just
wanted to address a couple — all right. Your wife.
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: So you mentioned I think that
she's the most important influence or the
biggest impact on you, your career. How so?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, and on life in general.
She brought — I think when you're a specialist
in an area, it's easy to get so fixated that
everything in your world revolves around
that. And mine was all around con artists,
thieves. And I had a soft spot for those guys. I
knew a lot of those guys, were intimate friends
of mine that had done things that — you would
think of like Ocean's Eleven, where they pulled
heists on casinos and switched out devices
and things. And I knew those guys well. And
that was my world. It was my cadre of team.
And around that time I had this weird inquiry
to do a TV show about picking up women. Just
because as a side thing people said, "Hey,
you seem to be really good at this thing." And I
wasn't ever a person who did notches on the belt,
but it's another thing, the perspective
taking, it's related to that and how you
establish rapport and things. And there's a friend
of mine who was taught hostage negotiation. He had
a special forces background. He says, "Hey,
why don't we do this book together and we'll
go shoot this video and we'll ask women how
they would like to be approached. And then
we'll put hidden cameras on them and see when
people approach them, how ridiculous people do
approach them. And then we'll talk about that."
And I said, "Sounds like a great idea." And he
calls me, he's got a film crew coming in and
some models and other things, and he says,
"Hey, we're having this thing, late night, at a
party in Las Vegas, at a all night spot." He says,
"Come." I said, "It's too late for me." He
says, "No, just come." And when I show up,
he's talking to a group of women. And I thought
they were probably escorts at that point.
Tim Ferriss: Professionals.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. Because
they were close to the VIP section. And it was a
small group, younger women, some older guys at the
table. And I'd seen that a lot in Vegas. But when
I get closer and I'm talking to them, and one of
the ladies in the group, as they were introducing
themselves, she had a background in psychobiology,
she had just graduated with a degree in that.
She was working as a crisis counselor on a
hotline talking people off the cliff. She would
do some pretty intense stuff and studied abnormal
psych and very kind of intense and playful.
And he said I was a thief when he introduced
me to this group of girls. And I stole —
Tim Ferriss: It is a hell of an intro,
you're going to get a conversation.
Apollo Robbins: It does. One of them said,
"Can I..." So I stole the girl's
engagement ring with the thing,
and I did a thing with that and gave it back. And
this lady, that later turned out to be my wife,
she asked me, "Can you steal something me
for me?" I said, "What would you like?"
She says, "A chocolate-covered strawberry from
that table over there." And she points at this
table nearby, a VIP section. I said, "Got it."
So I grabbed a menu, walked over, pretended to be
with the staff, asked them if they're being taken
care of, stole the chocolate strawberry under the
menu. And then I walked to her and then I threw it
over my shoulder to add a little flair, I caught
it. And went to hand it to her. And when she went
to take a bite of it, I put it in my mouth and I
just winked at her. So she'd have to kiss me to
get the strawberry. And it's that playfulness I
think that's the important thing.
Tim Ferriss:
It's bold. Bold. I like it. But it worked.
Apollo Robbins: It is. Yeah. But it almost
didn't work because her advocacy and her academia,
and it was the opposite, it was too slick. And she
felt that pressure from the group. She gave me
the kiss, but we ended up leaning against the
wall talking about psychology. And that dove
into a deep thing. She said, "Have you ever
thought about this..." Long phone conversations
later on. But she said, "Have you ever thought
about all this stuff you're learning and how
it applies to bigger problems in the world?"
And she was the one that encouraged me to do the
event with the neuroscientist. She was the one
that encouraged me to take the piece with The
New Yorker, which I didn't even know what The
New Yorker was at that point. I turned it down
twice. Adam Green would tell you. I was like,
"Here, somebody better over here." It
wasn't my thing. I didn't even barely
knew who the politicians were. It wasn't
my world. I didn't think about that.
She said, "Let me have you watch a debate."
And when I saw my first presidential debate,
I went back to Teller, I said, "Teller, you're a
Latin professor, what was that?" I said, "Why do I
know all those things? They're so similar to this
thing that the Yellow Kid used to do or Titanic
Thompson used to do this thing with this."
Tim Ferriss: Wait a second. Meaning you
observed a lot in the debate that
paralleled what you had learned.
Apollo Robbins: Very similar
concepts. And he said —
Tim Ferriss: Can you give an example?
Apollo Robbins: There is a term called Gish
galloping. I forgot the guy's name for Gish.
Tim Ferriss: Gish galloping.
Apollo Robbins: Gish was a debater who would often
do a package of assaults on a person, or of their
human character, where it should be. He'd say,
during his three-minute window of a debate,
he would say, "My adversary, my opponent, would
have you believe this, this, this, this, this."
And then the opponent, his countermeasure for
that, becomes, "Well..." They're overwhelmed.
And they don't know how to respond, because
they've got three minutes, and he posited
a lot of questions, and they don't have three
minutes, functionally, to answer those questions.
And that, very similar to me, was a
noise-to-signal ratio piece that's
used to overwhelm people inside of
a cash exchange with shortchanging.
And I recognize that as one approach.
Tim Ferriss: Shortchanging. Giving somebody
change, but less change than they should get back?
Apollo Robbins: And overwhelming a cash register
attendee at that time. And using
ambiguous statements with different
ways that they could take that as for
— and I can clarify more on that later.
But a counter to that Gish gallop,
for example, back to equivoque for
equivoke. If somebody were doing a series
of personal assassinations of — they also,
what they're doing, is diluting their argument.
Because now, if I say 10 bad things about you,
or you said that about me, then I'd say,
"As you can see, he's very impassioned
about what he says." But notice there's a
central theme between all of those. That
central theme is X. And that's the equivoque.
I can take all the things that you said, repackage
them as another thing, and because you diluted
all your points, because you put them all into
the one bracket,. so the countermeasure to that
is to dilute that down, give you one point back,
and I hijack the narrative.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So
you're talking to Teller about this.
Apollo Robbins: Yes. And he was a Latin professor.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. That wasn't
— I thought that was a euphemism
or a joke. He was an actual Latin professor?
Apollo Robbins: He was. Before, in his career,
I said that, "You know more about Socrates and
Plato, so can you tell me?" And he says, "Yeah,
you need to go back, read Plato's Republic. You
need to study about Socrates." And he started
prompting me to go back to learn this root.
Tim Ferriss: That's amazing.
Yeah. Back to the classics.
Apollo Robbins: Back to the classics.
Tim Ferriss: So, from the strawberry in the
mouth to broader applications in psychology,
or at least harnessing psychology, recognizing
maybe the common threads across multiple domains
that you'd already been exposed to, and had
polished in your craft — to presidential
debate, to then reading Plato and Aristotle.
Apollo Robbins: Yes. And the driver of this was,
back to that, was my wife. We had this unusual
thing in that she moved to Las Vegas pretty
quickly after we started dating.
Tim Ferriss: Where was she?
Apollo Robbins: She was in Los
Angeles. And at that point —
Tim Ferriss: Was it hard to
get her to move to Vegas?
Apollo Robbins: It was a negotiation. Because
she didn't want to come visit and be under
an obligation. And so when I asked her, I
said, "Please come visit me." And she said,
"I have a lot of work that I'm doing here, and
I don't currently have the money to do that."
And I said, "I understand. Can I ask? When you
write, what is your per page fee?" And she said,
"My per page fee is usually about this amount."
I said, "So, if I asked you to help me write
this bio and some other portions for me, I would
actually be getting a discount by paying for that,
by paying for your airplane versus
paying for the writer's fee."
And she said, "Yeah, I guess so." And I said,
"All right. So come help me write my bio,
and I'll buy you a plane ticket." When she came
out, she helped me have a different direction,
that I wasn't solely focused
on entertainment. And she also,
just because of her counseling background, she
really broke apart a lot of my early childhood.
And she had had these complexities, too.
She had moved from Vietnam. And she had
grown up — her father was incredible. He would
wear police uniforms and help people smuggle
things in and out of the country while she was
growing up. So she had these really interesting
engagements with deception, too, that she
was trying to manifest through psychology.
And at that time, I was consulting for a
mentalist named Derren Brown in the UK,
doing some things for him. She was fascinated by
that with her training in psychology. She says,
"Well, that's not exactly what that is."
And then, at that time, I had this
group of thieves around me that were
professional criminals, and she kind
of became a den mom to all them. If the FBI
was watching, or the NSA watching our house,
they would've seen all these guys coming in and
out. And she was the den mom of all them. And she
really helped take us all for a turn.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Okay. All right. This is off
the map. This has nothing to do with the questions
that I've written down. But I'm curious. When
you're describing, for instance, the semicircle
A to B versus the linear A to B, it makes me
think of sports and exercise science. And how the
practitioners, the people on the field — the top
coaches, the top athletes, are always a few years
ahead of the literature and the science and so on.
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Which is not to denigrate
the science. It just takes a while. People need
to write grants, typically. They need to really
pick and choose their shots. And a lot of what's
experimented within the field doesn't work. And
that's okay as long as a few things really work.
And I'm curious if, given that you have this
broader awareness, and you've had these
interactions with neuroscientists and so on,
if there are any beliefs you have based
on your experience as a practitioner,
around attention or perception, that has not
yet made its way into the scientific circles.
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: But you'd be willing to say,
"You know what? I can't say it with 100 percent
certainty, but I would bet that..." A, B, or C.
Apollo Robbins: I think, in order to validate the
research, they have to go after low-hanging fruit,
which is single variable. Real life
has context, and multivariable.
So when you go out in the wild, the reason why
it's sports, or — between Kahneman and Gary Klein,
they did a lot of research on first responders to
smoke jumpers and other things. The context of an
expertise is hard to boil down in a lab.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Super hard. Also,
really hard for replication with
animals. And, say, animal learning,
chimpanzees. Project Nim, for people who
are interested, highlights this. Very hard.
Apollo Robbins: Fascinating. And the
society aspect of that, for example,
and the replication of that, tend to show
the same darkness of an ideal society. And
what does that mean, to manufacture one?
In the space where I find fascinating
probably with the current research, I'm really
interested, like an armchair social psychologist,
that — I really read a lot in that space. That
harkens back to my dad and my childhood. Which is,
I think that there's a really interesting
place right now, when people focus in politics
on the left and the right, that there's a bigger
problem with how people engage with uncertainty.
That there needs to be a lot of work done on
the study of the tolerance that people have for
uncertainty. And we've had the pandemic, we've
had the craziness, we've had the economy. And
I think it's really interesting if you look
at that as the — instead of left and right.
If you look at that as north and south, that
you have people from both sides that need an
absolute answer when they're confronted with
something unusual, and that need to fill in
the gap, that need to have an absolute
answer for something that they've seen
happen — versus a tolerance for uncertainty, I
think could help inoculate people from some of
the problems that they're running into.
There's going to be a future
where, with the arms race — people think of it as
arms race of technology when they think about AI,
deepfakes. But it's our arms race of imaginations.
And tends to be, thieves will beat you to it.
They'll be innovating in that space
pretty quickly, and they are right now
with deepfakes and other things. And it's
useful to see how people are going to deal
with having something that looks very real.
You're now in this very interesting time
that all the research historically for mankind,
with deception, tends to be on spotting a lie,
spotting something that's fake. And I think
we're on a cusp where that's going to flip over,
and we're going to have to try to spot the
truth. And what does that mean in the future?
Tim Ferriss: Terrifying.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. Where
you've got to spot the truth, and how do you
deal with that? And I think that's really — there
needs to be a lot more research on how
we develop comfort with uncertainty,
how we authenticate all those types of things.
And there's books and literature that's starting
to come out of that space, and that's definitely
— I'm leaning into that, too. Because, I feel
like since my job is distorting perceptions
and creating erroneous sense making, then I
should really try to lend a helping hand if I can.
Tim Ferriss: We may come back to that. But I want
to first return to something that we discussed
briefly, but didn't really flesh out. And that is,
let's call it, for lack of a better term,
your style. Before we get to your style,
what is the significance, if any, of that ring?
Apollo Robbins: This ring is made from a silver
coin. And my magic used to be based around
silver. And it's unusual. If you talk to a
magician, professional magicians tend to —
Tim Ferriss: A very pretty ring. And for
people who aren't watching the video, I've been
watching you play with it, and manipulate it,
and take it off and put it back on. And I would
imagine, given what you do, that you might
choose your adornments with some thought.
Apollo Robbins: Yes, all with a purpose.
Tim Ferriss: That's why I ask. All right.
Apollo Robbins: Everything has a purpose.
There's lots of things that can be done
with this. Actually, when I pickpocketed
Penn Jillette — I met him the first time,
and he's a big guy, six foot six, at least.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Big guy.
Apollo Robbins: And he had heard about,
historically among magicians, pickpockets are a
kind of a fake. There's a lot of people that say,
"Give me your wallet before the show," and then
they'd steal it out. And I didn't have that
background. I came from a different lane. And he
had heard from a friend that I could really steal.
So he put me on the spot in front of a bunch
of people, first time I met him. He just walked
up to me, he says, "So you can steal stuff."
And I said, "Yeah, sometimes I can." He says,
"Then steal something from me."
He held out his arms. And I remember
him wearing a Tommy Bahama shirt and some
shorts. And he had a Montblanc pen that
was clipped inside of his shirt pocket. And he
said, "Steal something from me now." And I said,
"That's kind of like saying 'Be funny now.'"
He said, "Yeah." I said, "Let me tell you
about something that happened to somebody
one time. If I steal a watch from someone,
it's one plus one. You say, 'Oh, you're
fast. You got my watch. I didn't notice.'"
I said, "But one time I was talking to a guy, and
during the conversation I stole his pen and I took
the inside ink pen, the refill of his pen out.
Put his pen back together, put it back in place,
and later I was asking him to sign something.
And when he went to sign it, he couldn't. He
realized he couldn't. He went to write it down."
And he says, "Okay, yeah. Are you going to steal
something from me?" I said, "Can you draw a circle
around this ring for me?" And he pulled out his
pen to go do it. And he stops and he stares at
me, and he realizes he's the guy in the story.
And he just sat back and he opened his pen and
saw that the refill wasn't there. And he goes,
"Fuck you." And I said, "Now, Penn, isn't
that better than taking your wallet?"
And I threw his wallet on the table.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. That's amazing. Now,
why is that made of a silver dollar?
Apollo Robbins: Silver dollars in coin magic,
silver has a unique property, in the way that
it feels on your skin. The way it's soft,
the way it can move. And also, the sound that
it makes. But specifically, for sleight of hand,
silver works very well for sleight of hand.
As a memory of that, even when I'm not performing,
I had one converted into a ring. So they punched
a hole and rolled it into this ring. And it's
a reminder to me of where I came from for that.
Tim Ferriss: Very cool. Very attention grabbing,
also. Which I would imagine helps
with what you just described.
Apollo Robbins: It can be used. It can be used as
a level of confidence I can talk to you about. And
I'll show you something with that, actually.
Because it does mean a lot to me. Do you have
anything in your pockets right now?
Tim Ferriss: I do, yeah. I have
a hotel key. I have some credit cards.
Apollo Robbins: Okay, great. And I appreciate you
letting me know where those are. If I asked you
right now, and this is something we could just —
Tim Ferriss: I just fell for it. "Got you, bitch."
Apollo Robbins: Set your pen down for a second.
And take my ring, and put it in one of your hands.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Apollo Robbins: And now, whether under the paper,
behind your back, put in one of your two hands so
I can't see which hand it would go in.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. I'll do it behind my
back. It's going to be a little tight.
Apollo Robbins: Sorry about that. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That's all right.
Apollo Robbins: You got it? So
you put in one of your hands. Now, don't do the
third option, which is putting it in your pocket.
Tim Ferriss: No, not going to do that.
Apollo Robbins: Okay. Bring both your
hands out. Now I'll try to guess which hand.
Right now it's in your right hand. Correct?
Tim Ferriss: It is in my right hand.
Apollo Robbins: Can I see?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Apollo Robbins: Okay. Do that again.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Apollo Robbins: Okay? Just bring it
back out. Now it's in the left hand.
Tim Ferriss: Correct.
Apollo Robbins: Is that right? Let me see.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it is.
Apollo Robbins: You try that with me. Okay?
Tim Ferriss: All right. Yeah, I was trying
to think, logic through this sort of like Rock,
Paper, Scissors. Because I was like, "He would
expect me to probably go with the same hand,
because I would maybe think I should switch it." I
sort of overcomplicated it for myself. But yes —
Apollo Robbins: Which is
Princess Bride all over again.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It was Princess
Bride all over again.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. Try it with
me and see what your process is. Okay?
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Apollo Robbins: All right.
Tim Ferriss: Right hand.
Apollo Robbins: It was pretty fast.
Did you peek it, or how did you get it?
Tim Ferriss: No, I was
looking at the body language.
Apollo Robbins: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, shit. I already —
Apollo Robbins: You're distracted? I'll do it
again. I'll do it again. Hold on. All right,
so we're doing a second time. There you go.
Tim Ferriss: Left hand.
Apollo Robbins: Left hand. It's a big move.
Because fixation would say "Stay there." You're
now assuming that I took the same pattern as
you. I switched to the other hand. I could
try to talk you out of that to go back to the
wrong choice. But you made the right choice. I
need you to miss so I can make my point. Just one
more time. All right, one more time. Which hand?
Tim Ferriss: Right hand.
Apollo Robbins: Would you like to change?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Apollo Robbins: So, this is not
a minimalism effect, or it'd be much better.
Tim Ferriss: But I also have 50/50 chance.
Apollo Robbins: 50/50 chance, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But I want you
to be able to make your point.
Apollo Robbins: Well, so in this,
that's a little mini con with a little ring.
And we often hear people talk about biases,
like confirmation bias. But when you embody
a real interaction like this, you would never
associate what we just did as confirmation bias.
Tim Ferriss: I think I have an advantage over you,
also. Because you're angled to me.
Apollo Robbins: Oh, okay. You were
able to see, kind of, when my hand came out.
Tim Ferriss: I didn't see your hands. But I
think it's easier for me to observe your body
language in a sense, because you're angled that
way. But that might be wrong. I don't know.
Apollo Robbins: No, it's an interesting
hypothesis. But I think that that's
the interesting thing. That if it was
never in my hand, and you were wrong every
time, you might think I was cheating. Yes?
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Apollo Robbins: Because when we lose,
we're more curious. And when we win, we're
less curious about why we're winning. Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Okay. So now, for those people
who are watching, now you have identical rings,
one in each hand. Okay, got it.
Apollo Robbins: A very unique,
special ring that you started the conversation on.
You found your own path. So in that, that's little
metaphor for a con. Right? That one little ring.
Because that whole story that you jumped into,
that little rabbit hole with asking about the
ring, is a great baseline that now people assume
there's one, and there's that baseline piece.
But to me, that is that greater question that
when we're succeeding, we're often not curious
why we're having success. And it's a very unusual
thing for us to say, "Well, let me check
out the other hand," when you win. Right?
Tim Ferriss: When you win, yeah.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. But that's confirmation
bias. And it's really helpful —
Tim Ferriss: 100 percent.
Apollo Robbins: — to know what that is. And it's
very easy. You didn't jump into the hole like
most people do. Most people will say, "Well, I've
played poker with my grandma since I was four. I'm
really good at reading people." And they walk
away with this confidence. And that's the con
aspect of that. But in this one —
Tim Ferriss: Right. Confidence.
Apollo Robbins: It is.
Tim Ferriss: Confidence man, confidence.
Apollo Robbins: You see me playing low status
with that. I need you to miss, in order for
me to be able to — but that kind of thing,
everything is about helping people get to that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. All right. That was a great
demo. And that actually ties into the question of,
can you elaborate on what makes your style.
How is it different from what people think
of as magic, maybe what they've seen growing up?
Apollo Robbins: I'll give you an experience one
time. Where I had — I'll let you just see kind
of backstage. One time I was performing for a
corporate event in Las Vegas. And it's similar
to the one where I had the broken watch piece,
but this is a bit later in my career.
And it was a new agent, and I was talking to
her off to the side. And I met a couple of the
people that were there, one of the ladies who
ran the thing named Lisa, several other people.
But then this other guy came up. Well-dressed guy,
and he said, "So, I heard you steal things. Is
that right?" And I said, "Yeah, something like
that." "So steal something from me." I said,
"I'm sorry. What was your name?" He says,
"Jamal." I said, "Nice to meet you, Jamal."
And before this, let's go back. That I walked
into this event thinking, "I don't want to do
anything I've done before, exactly." There's some
little components, and you'll hear some things
coming back where I just talked about with Penn.
But I knew that I could figure out how
to put something inside of a bag of M&Ms,
and then reseal it in real time without
anybody noticing. And I thought, "What could
I do with that? Let's just find out."
And that's where it started to become
a jazz. So this interaction with this guy,
Jamal, when he just came up, he says, "So,
you can steal something from me?" And I said, "I
don't rightly know. What was your name?" He goes,
"Jamal." I said, "How do you spell that,
Jamal?" And he said, "J, A…" I said,
"Could you write that down for me?"
And he pulls out his pen and he goes
to write it down, and his pen wasn't working,
as we've heard before. And up to this point, my
stuttering, the break of my speech, the break of
my sight lines with him, has been very low status.
Tim Ferriss: Break of your
sight lines meaning eye contact?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. I didn't keep straight
eye contact with him very much. I asked him
about his suit, "That's really fancy." It
was all low status. And then everything
just changed. Then it's this thing. I
said, "Would this help you out, Jamal?"
And it's straight eye contact, and it's the refill
to his ink pen. And he had way underestimated,
and stepped way too close, he realized
suddenly. And when that moment happened to him,
you saw him holding his pen with one
hand and his refill with the other. And
he was just looking, and he's stunned.
He's in this cycle of trying to make
that — because the only solution it could be
is the one he didn't want to accept. So he's
canceled out the truth. Where is he going to go
from there? That I had stolen it, taken it apart,
put it back together, and put it back on him.
Couldn't be that. So what else could it be?
Pausing time, time travel. So in that, now
at that moment, while he's in that bewildered
state, I just said, "Well, at least you
didn't lose your money or your wallet."
And when I did that, I just glanced down. Because
I noticed he has his watch on his left wrist,
so he's probably right-handed. So he's
probably going to keep his wallet in his
back right. So I just glanced back, toward his
back right pocket. And he jumped on that big.
He reached in, pulled out his wallet real
quick, checked to see if he had everything
still in his wallet. And I laughed, and
I saw his attention shift back to the
pen. And I pushed down his hand. I said, "You
still have everything." And he put it away.
And he says, "You've got to do this to Lisa." I
said, "Yeah, great to meet her." I just looked
over his shoulder to where I thought Lisa might
be. And he took off to go get Lisa. Comes back,
and he shoves this lady towards
me, and this agent. And I'm —
Tim Ferriss: "Dance, monkey. Dance."
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. Well, I'm there to perform.
Tim Ferriss: No, I know. I know.
Apollo Robbins: And I'm talking to the
agent. I have a drink. And this is an important
thing, the drink, just because it's a part of
the style. It's not alcohol, it's just water.
But it's that I don't need anything from him.
I'm not being validated. And a lot of
performers will try to spoon feed the
audience. But it's letting them bring a thing to
them. Letting them have a reaction without you
needing to feed back off of it. And letting
people have this experience for themselves.
So when he pushed the lady up, I didn't quite look
at her at first. I said, "Sorry. It's nice to meet
you." I looked over and I said, "What was your
name?" She goes, "Lisa." And she hadn't quite come
close to me at all. She said, "What's happening?"
I said, "Sorry, Lisa. He wants me to steal
something from you." She says, "What?" I said,
"Do you like chocolate?" She says, "Chocolate?"
I said, "Yes. There's some chocolate in your
purse." She said, "What?" She opens her purse,
and she finds a bag of M&Ms in her purse.
And he's reacting very strongly to this. And
he's watching this third party, he thinks.
And then she said, "How did those get in my
purse?" And I said, "The same way Jamal's
driver's license got out of his wallet."
Now he's jumped back into the equation.
He rips his wallet out again, realizes
his license is missing. And he goes, "Where in
the fuck is my driver's license?" And I said,
"It's in the chocolate," as I take a
sip of my water. And I just walk away.
So I let them piece it together
themselves. She tears open the M&Ms,
and she finds the license in her thing.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. If we zoom out, then, amazing
story. I would have to think 100 percent, maybe
99.999 percent of people listening, have never
experienced something like this. What are the
ingredients? You mentioned some of them. Are there
other ingredients that you can call out explicitly
that are some of the hallmarks that differentiate?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. And part of
that that's quite different in magic,
is it tends to be that they'll have a set of
effects that are linked together. In that one,
I walked in trying — I had a set of skills that
I could do, but I hadn't pieced them together.
And I take advantage of the movement, like
you would if you were sparring in that way.
When he leaned in forward, I stepped back with my
left foot. And I said, "It's nice to meet you."
But at the same time as my right hand
comes up, with the back of my hand,
I kind of put my hand towards his chest as he came
in a little bit too close, my left hand came up
underneath the sight line and slipped inside of
his jacket, and took out his pen really quick.
And I went down the line of my arm and into
my pocket, so he couldn't see anything being
extracted. And then I stepped back. And then I
removed the pen, took it apart, and I find another
reason to come back in to put it back there.
Tim Ferriss: It's so outrageous that you
can do any of this. It's amazing,
Apollo Robbins: But it's a strange
thing. And then, each one of those moments,
on the backside of that, is I didn't know what
was going to happen. But what I saw is when his
attention locked to that pen, and he was spinning.
And you can think of attention as being external
or internal, inside your head or external,
aware. And you can think of it as being broad or
narrow. And on those axes, it's very useful of,
"Do I want him to be broad/external or
do I want him to be internal/narrow?"
And how do I flip somebody from one of those to
the other? And I'm very attuned to doing that,
of moving people between those four stages. So
that was a big part there, was to do that to him.
And when he pulled that out, and he thought he had
the money, I just copped his driver's license out
of his wallet and let him put his wallet back.
But he was already still thinking about the pen,
so I could see he was thinking about
the pen. So when I pushed down his hand,
I just took the wallet out. The problem is
his train of thought would go straight back
to it if I reveal, "Oh, I've got your
license," he would go straight to it.
So I thought, "I guess I'm going to put this
license inside the M&Ms. Let me see how I can
do that." And as I'm thinking about that, he
said, "Well, you should meet Lisa." I was like,
"What a great idea."
Tim Ferriss: Perfect.
Apollo Robbins: Yes. And I think she's the one
I met. Maybe there's more Lisas, but let's see
where he goes. And I said, "Yeah, that'd be nice
to meet her." So he goes off, and he takes off to
get Lisa. I see another Lisa that I have met.
So just in case, I put it inside the M&Ms,
and then I walk over while this other lady, Lisa,
is talking to these people. I open her purse,
drop it in there, put it there, and then I
go back to where I was. He doesn't know this.
Tim Ferriss: So it was the right Lisa.
Apollo Robbins: It was, lucky for me. Otherwise,
I'd have to be doing some introductions.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So, I have to ask,
what is it like for your wife to have a fight
or argument with you? Because, it could be,
seems like it could be a total nightmare.
Or she would have to become such a master
in your craft to be able to mount a defense.
Or that she would be like — I have some friends
who are therapists, and sometimes their kids will
say, "Stop therapizing me, Mom." And they'll be
like, "I know what you're doing." And they're
like — so, what does that dynamic look like?
Or is she like, "Weapons, badge on the table.
Take your tools, put them away. I don't want
any of your horseshit. We need to have a talk."
Apollo Robbins: It'd be easier to have game on,
game off. I think we don't. We do use it
in our social interactions with each other,
as well. But she does it, too. Her career
path, she became a mentalist. She left her
career as a psychobiologist.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, all right.
This is non-trivial. Okay.
Apollo Robbins: It's huge. She
studied mentalism after meeting Derren Brown. She
went deep down that. She started performing for
companies. But she had the background to science
that I didn't have. So she'd translate for me.
We had a daughter together a number
of years later. And in between those,
we had these unusual experiences of going in very
dangerous places with different criminal groups,
to learn about them together. Me and her
on these adventures around the world,
in different strange places.
Tim Ferriss: Why did you do
that? To learn what types of things?
Apollo Robbins: Well, it's easy to
say that a magic trick comes from this
book. It's a different thing to say,
"But where did this really come from? Where
did this idea really come from?" A certain
type of pocket, or a certain type of thing.
And there were legends of people doing things
in certain places. There's these group of
women called the 40 Elephants that used to
be in the UK. And around probably 1890 to the
1940s, they ran a criminal group there. And
they could steal large amount of things
by altering their clothing, and doing a
variation of what's called boosters or boosting.
And that's my world, an encyclopedia of things
like that. And who's the people that are doing it
now? There's a resurgence of footage showing up,
now that YouTube is so pervasive with security
cameras, of women doing things that are like that.
Where they're stealing a flatscreen TV, 32-inch
flatscreen TV, and putting it underneath their
dress, and walking without changing their
gait. Or taking 10-pound cases of beer or wine,
and just making it vanish in their clothing.
And walking without changing their walk.
There's a very interesting thing there that
it becomes, "How is that knowledge being
transferred?" It probably goes back to at least
the one data point I know, the 40 Elephants.
Usually, when I interact with different cultures
of these, I track back through signals that they
use, or language or terms that they use. And
I try to track where they learn from. And we
chased after that. Eva and I did that a lot.
So, to your original question, how do we, as
a couple, we both are fascinated by that space. We
now have a kid. And I'd say it's more interesting,
probably, for our kid, of trying to teach her.
We don't teach her that it's bad to lie. We
try to talk to her that deception is a social
lubricant. It happens all the time around us,
from the moment we put on makeup to something
else. So, whether it be a defeat for cancer
by using decoy cells, there's all these
things that have a reason. But it's about
your intent, and that's the big thing.
Tim Ferriss: Could you say more about
that? Because that would be very heretical
to, I'm sure, some people listening. Like,
"Wait a second. No. Deception bad."
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Right?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: No exceptions. Black and white.
That's the dark side of the Force. Could you
say a bit more about how you teach your
child, your children, about deception? Or
if you want to tackle this a different way,
is there a pro-social or a positive use of
deception, and a way to frame that for people?
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely. And that's definitely
the flag I fly under now. Is I think that
there's value in learning about deception.
One of the reasons why we have critical thinking
is to counter deception. And it's helpful now when
people say, "We need more critical thinking," to
understand what was the original reason for it.
Why did we need this reasoning process? Inside
of a communal culture, we need to understand
the role of deception. And there's been chases
in the history of the study of the psychology,
of deception. Of trying to say,
"Well, let's catch somebody in a lie."
Or, "Lying is all bad," but it's not. We use
lies and levels of disclosure on our first
dates. It's funny if you hear me now, versus what
my father's thinking would've been as a child.
"Sorry, my son is advocating for deception."
But what I'm advocating for is an awareness of
what deception is, and expanding the horizons
of what people think it can be. And I'll give
you an example. Take the concepts that are used.
If I can make — here's a concept: I'm going to
make someone think that they have acted when
they haven't. That's a very generic concept.
Tim Ferriss: Make them think that they have —
Apollo Robbins: Acted on something. Taken an
action when they haven't. I'll give you two
contexts for that. If I, as a pickpocket,
steal from somebody in another country, and
they are not too familiar with the language,
and I run away, their response will
typically be to yell for police.
One way of stopping that is to have a
second member of my team come up to them
while they're emotionally charged, and to
take a police report. Give them a ticket,
and they think they have acted when they haven't.
They have a peace of mind that they've taken some
action. And while they're emotionally charged,
what do they need to see? Maybe a clipboard,
a badge, a couple of things. And
I don't need to show them much.
But that concept, if you can distill the concept
of that, how do I fight malaria? It's female
mosquitoes that bite, that create the transfer
of the germ in malaria. But if I can release a
hormone to a female mosquito, to make her
think that she has mated when she hasn't,
I make her think that she has behaved, taken
an action when she hasn't taken the action.
And you can stop the spread of malaria.
It's the same concept. So this use of
deception is really the broader aspect.
How do we deceive a cell? How do we
deal with the coronavirus? It can be used in
medicine; it can be used in different areas.
Using truth to deceive, that's a very
powerful thing. It's the difference
between malinformation versus disinformation.
Malinformation is the use of true facts to
deceive. And paltering is the name for it
in business, of using it in advertising,
of using a series of true statements to mislead.
Tim Ferriss: Can you give an example? I've
never heard that term before.
Apollo Robbins: Which, paltering?
Tim Ferriss: Paltering, yeah.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah,
paltering. If I said —
Tim Ferriss: It doesn't
have to be a business example, but what would
be an example of using the truth to deceive?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. Well, if I release a
series of true statements in a certain order,
you are going to connect those and tell yourself
a story. If you vet any of those true elements,
they will show up to be true. But because
they were delivered to you in a certain order,
they'll create a belief. And that's the bigger
thing. How do I craft a belief in you? That's
been done a variety of ways on both sides of the
political spectrum that we could say. It's done
in advertising as well. It was done — there's
a great book on propaganda by Eddie Bernays,
where he explored it with doing a study
on the most important meal of the day.
It was at that time, I think, funded
by the pork industry. They found that
breakfast was the most important meal of the day.
He said, so the all-American breakfast, bacon,
eggs, and toast, is the most important.
That wasn't part of the original study,
the bacon and the eggs to become part of the
all-American breakfast, but repackaging that
in there as well. A smaller thing, if I want to
convey an implied statement to you, if I said,
"Do you believe in ESP?"
Tim Ferriss: Sure. Yes.
Apollo Robbins: Then I don't have anything to do.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Let's say, let's go with no,
then. Not sure where this is going!
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, so if you say no,
I "Say some people don't believe in ESP."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Apollo Robbins: "And soome people don't
believe we ever walked on the moon."
Both those statements are true by implying a third
statement that now if you don't believe in ESP,
that you're similar to the people with conspiracy
theories who never believe we walked on the moon.
Tim Ferriss: Right. You're
making a false association.
Apollo Robbins: Association. By using true
statements. So it's also as a legality,
it's a lot harder thing to grab onto. If
I want to pull back one layer further.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's slippery.
Apollo Robbins: It is.
Tim Ferriss: I mean there's a lot of room for
deception in advertising and product marketing
also. So I didn't know that term, but there's a
term called puffery, which is, it's an implied
structure or function claim. You can't make
structure or function claims, for instance with
dietary supplements or in shampoo because then
it would be governed by the FDA. It would be,
and I'm simplifying this, but classified as a drug
and therefore you would have to go through all of
these different steps and studies and so on. To
avoid that, so puffery is the use of words that
have basically no meaning whatsoever.
Apollo Robbins: Okay. Gibberish.
Tim Ferriss: So if you sell shampoo that is a
hair volumizer, no agreed upon or legal definition
of a volumize, but it conjures an image.
Apollo Robbins: It does.
Tim Ferriss: Of a very distinct effect.
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: It's total bullshit.
Tim Ferriss: When you have a label for this
and you get a few examples, you start to see it
everywhere. It's all over the place, in any case.
Apollo Robbins: That's exactly to my point. I
hope that people expand beyond just trying to
catch them in a lie because many of the things
now that are impacting people in major ways
are going beyond fabrication. They're going
to narratives that craft belief systems. So my
push that I think is a nice way to stay off the
political phrase just to go after, how about I
show you how these things are traditionally done?
I'm going to show you the anatomy of those. I'm
going to try to familiarize you with those that,
like I said, deception awareness.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I see. You're saying,
"Okay, we can talk about politics or a modern
incarnation of this type of perceptual shaping,
but let's do it vis-a-vis the 40 Elephants."
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, because my goal,
if I attack a political piece and the outcome of
the behavior I'd like is I would like for people
to move more center, I want there to be a kind
of diplomacy between people, all right, that's
the very nature of politics. So can I get them
off the extremes? I believe that teaching them
without having to target them with their current
beliefs, to use these other metaphors instead of
a turtle, I'm using cons and other deception.
To another point of something more ambiguous,
I talked about change raising earlier,
shortchanging somebody, a cashier. If I want to be
softer in that I could just as a sleight of hand
artist, I have the ability to change a bill from
one bill to another. I can do that very quickly.
So do thieves. If I go to a cashier and I said,
"Can you give me a hundred dollar bill and I
give you 10 $10 bills?" That doesn't raise a
lot of suspicion in the way that a hundred bill
would in the other way where they vet that.
Now you take those 10 10s, you put them in
the register, you hand them to me and I take
the hundred. I just look at the hundred and I
say, "Excuse me." When you look at the hundred,
you see now there's a 10 there instead of
a hundred, what is my claim? I just said,
"Excuse me," I didn't tell you that you gave me
the wrong thing. I didn't make a bolster of a
claim. I'm just allowing you to assume a story.
Tim Ferriss: Write your own story.
Apollo Robbins: If you assume the wrong story
and think you made a mistake and gave me a 10
instead of a hundred, you're going to take that
back, give me a hundred, and I made $90. If you
went the other way and you were highly suspicious,
you're on top of it and you say, "What?" I said,
"Could you give me two fives?" So that allows me
to go either way. I have this 10, I can take that
lane, "Can you give me two fives?" That's what it
means by equivocate. So the equivocation of those
things is this ambiguity used to deceive
that can be taken in multiple directions.
Tim Ferriss: Although you're kind of
fucked on that exchange, because you —
Apollo Robbins: It helps to
be able to have the recording.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so I want to talk for
a second about books. So when you were younger,
there were these various books.
You mentioned a few of them. One
of them was J.B. Bobo's Coin Magic.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, that was the
book that Ben Stone gave me. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Right. Had a large
impact on your life, your thinking, and
so on. Are there books in later chapters
that have had an impact on you that come to mind?
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely. Specific points. There
was one where some people that I had worked with
started to say, it was almost an implication that
they thought I was psychic and I wasn't buying
into that. There was an incident that happened.
Somebody had stolen something from me at that show
at Caesars Palace with hundreds of people. I had
a backpack and somebody got there and stole out
a set of special coins that I had that were very
sentimental to me, inside of a case.
Tim Ferriss: That's a bummer.
Probably of no use to them.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. It was
both emotional and significant to me. I had
come back up, I just changed in my street
clothes and I said, "Hey, was somebody in my
bag?" The ticket ladies didn't know. I said,
"What did they look like?" They said,
"Yeah, there's a guy back here." I said,
"Old, young, dark hair, light hair?"
They said, "I'm not sure." I said,
"Did he go in the show route or did he go side
door?" They said, "Side door." I said, "So he's
in the Illuminarium," which is like a couple
hundred people in that space now. They said,
"Yeah, he's there." I was like, oh, man. I
said, "Can you spot him if we go in there?"
We go in and when I go look for him, I ended up
finding this guy out of a couple hundred people.
Tim Ferriss: Because they helped you spot him?
Apollo Robbins: No, they didn't know how to
describe him. I called my boss and I said,
"Hey, can we do an announcement? Somebody
stole my stuff. Can you do an announcement that we
know that they stole it?" He says, "No." I said,
"All right." So then I went back in and changed
in my uniform for the show and I went through
everybody's pockets. I started going through
assessing and profiling a few hundred people.
I found the guy and it was just you were
eliminating different people. Grandpa's
not going to do this. This guy's got his
family, he's not going to take that chance.
So I narrowed down to couples and other things
and then I see this guy and he's with another
girl. I went up to him and I said, "Hey,
man, what's your name?" He goes, "Slick."
Tim Ferriss: Slick.
Apollo Robbins: He called himself Slick. I mean,
that's not the thing. As I went by, he was wearing
jogging pants and he only had something in his
front left pocket. So I tapped the thing, not tap
tap, but enough for me to know what it was and it
was my case. So then I stole it back from him
without him knowing. I went and told my boss,
"Hey, I found this guy. Can you call security?"
He said, he's laughing. He's just like, "No."
Tim Ferriss: You took the evidence.
Apollo Robbins: He says, "But how
can you find this guy?" He says, "What?"
He's telling everybody else. At that time,
back to your book's question, I always get on
tangents. I really wanted to understand what was
happening there. I was like, is it NLP? Everybody
says NLP, is that what this is? It wasn't that.
Tim Ferriss: What you were
doing, or what he was doing?
Apollo Robbins: People were thinking about what
I was doing as far as — I didn't believe it was,
I had super skills.
Tim Ferriss: So you
were trying to deconstruct what you yourself —
Apollo Robbins: I was pushing at the science. So
I found out about Robert Cialdini and his book on
influence and different studies on the history of
persuasion. I started ordering textbooks from
universities and really going into that. Then
now my areas of interest, the nice thing is I'm
friends with a lot of the authors that I know.
So Dan Simons just wrote a book called Nobody's
Fool, that is going specifically after a problem
that I'm very interested in, which is if we posit
this idea that we need more critical thinking,
we really need to define what critical
thinking is. Critical thinking I think
is being used as a filler term to fill in the
blank whenever we've got a problem for reasoning.
I think it needs to be more specific
than that to solve the problem. What
behavior do we want to change? Do we want
people to have an alternate hypothesis to
question their hypothesis? When is that the
case and when is that a conspiracy theory?
It now becomes the fixation on beliefs. When
should we question what we think we know? That's
a very specific thing. So a lot of the things I'm
reading right now are how beliefs are constructed.
When should we question what we think we know?
How often do we update our belief systems? Is
there a firmware that needs to be updated? How
do we go about doing that? I'm trying to find
what my role is in trying to help with that.
Tim Ferriss: Outside of technical magic books,
and I'm using magic broadly, could be any
facet of that type of performance. What
books have you reread that come to mind?
Apollo Robbins: That I read quite a bit?
One that I'm hovering around right
now, I say that I'm rereading it,
but I'm going to be soft on the title, I think
it's called How Minds Are Changed. It's an
important book that goes into the impact of deep
canvassing and is it possible to change someone's
mind in a conversation within any lasting
results? What is the process of doing that?
That's different than in a traditional magic book.
Also, when should you and why should you? It poses
the idea of questioning your own beliefs and how
you arrived at those and how necessary it is for
you to update yours. I go back to that quite
a bit. There's a book called The Person and
This Situation. I think it's Nisbett.
Tim Ferriss: We can get all this,
we'll put them in the show notes as well.
Apollo Robbins: I'll give you a list of those
because I do suffer from that when I buy a book,
I think I'm going to buy the time to read it. I
do have several that I go back to repeatedly. It
tends to be that they are for specific functions
of the things that are driving me in life. A
friend of mine wrote a book called Deception
in the Digital Age, and he was with the FBI.
His name is Cameron Malin. It's a fascinating
book in that space that I go into a lot.
Tim Ferriss: Does Whiz Mob hold any special
place in your heart or mind?
Apollo Robbins: Yes, it did.
Tim Ferriss: What is Whiz Mob?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, so okay,
if you go to books as to the spirit of your
question, which is what I should have listened to.
Tim Ferriss: I don't blame you for not
listening to my spirit. It's an acquired taste.
Apollo Robbins: There's probably, so Bobo's Coin
Magic, right? Then there was the Fitzkee books
that Ben Stone tricked me into reading.
Tim Ferriss: God bless that guy.
Apollo Robbins: They still reverberize because
it's magic, and then the study of misdirection.
Then Whiz Mob. Whiz Mob was that it was this
juxtaposition that there was a professor,
David Maurer, who was studying the language
of thieves. He wrote two books. He wrote The
American Confidence Man, which later became Big
Con. It was one chapter of that was turned into
the book, or into the movie [The] Sting. That
influenced a lot of other parts of that book were
turned into elements for other movies that are
cons and heist movies. I was very interested in,
because he was a language professor who
was studying the language of thieves.
Whiz Mob was a specific type of theft. It's
not just a pickpocket on the street. The name
of Whiz Mob is this idea that there are thieves
that travel and they don't just work as a team,
but there are some thieves that have learned
all the roles in a team. They could shift
between those roles so they didn't need the
team anymore and they were called cannons.
This term came back from the UK a long time
ago. Maurer was tracing that back and he
noticed that it was showing up in Chicago and
other places that the cannons were around. He
started to meet some people that were coming into
Louisville, Kentucky for I guess the Kentucky
Derby for this event. He found that there were
groups of cannons that would find each other
internationally and play as bigger teams.
They were fascinating. It was hard for
surveillance to catch them because they could
change their composition as a team, change their
tactics, and they had very different skill levels.
That lit a fire for me to try to find a cannon, to
try to find Whiz Mob. The New Yorker article that
is all about that, of me finding my first cannon.
Then a year ago when I moved to Washington DC,
another cannon reached out to me by email and
said, "Hey, we have similar interests with
Maurer's work. I'm one of the original Whiz
Mob." I said, "What?" I said, "Well, that's an
easy thing to vet." So it's in writing. So I
got to vet this guy out. He talked about when
he was 14 years old and he was a six-foot-four
black man coming to, at that time it was very
hard to get in someone's space. So he had to
invent whole new approaches to stealing, also
what racism meant in that kind of community.
He was writing a book about that. He wanted to
get together with me. He lives in the DC area.
We still haven't got together. So sometime if
you want to get together with the two of us.
Tim Ferriss: I'm in.
Apollo Robbins: That is the driver. That's
where I used to spend a lot of my time. That book,
Maurer's book, taught me to be a student of these
arcane disciplines and see what I could learn.
Tim Ferriss: So a question on arcane discipline
as it applies to the team roles. People may
be familiar with the different positions on
an American football team or basketball
team, probably are not familiar with the
different roles that a cannon could take. So
what does a team of thieves look like? Or at
least what are some of the fundamental roles?
Apollo Robbins: I think a lot of people don't
know the structure of a pickpocket team. They
tend to know football, basketball, baseball, very
intimately and very impassioned. For pickpocket
team it tends to be different. There are names —
Tim Ferriss: It's their intention not to be seen.
Apollo Robbins: It is, yes. There's names for
them. Historically, the wire, the stick, the
shade, the stall, and they all have functions
in what people would think is, oh, that's just
a diversion. It's more than that. As you move
from country to country, there's different
approaches of how people steal in one country
versus another. It tends to be that you see them
move like a school of fish through a crowd. So
if somebody's in an event and they've locked
onto a target, as that target moves through,
whether it's a casino or an event, you'll see
the thieves move with them as a school of fish.
The roles with that, the wire is kind of
embodied in a character from a movie called
Harry Never Holds. It was about a pickpocket
that would steal from people and he would hand
off his stuff because if anybody rolled him
up, he's the quarterback. They don't want to
catch the quarterback, because he's the most
valuable player. That functions as a metaphor.
So how would he pass? Who would he pass to?
The other roles in the team become the stalls
or the sticks, which they set up a frame, they
stop somebody's elbow from moving backwards and
grabbing hold of the thieves hand. They might open
a newspaper, they might look at a book if it's on
a subway, but they're going to be underneath the
edge of an elbow so a hand can't get back. That's
what I mean setting a frame on someone.
Tim Ferriss: Running interference.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. So they came and moved
back. Then there's the shade, the shade is
counter surveillance, they're looking to identify
undercover law enforcement. As they scope through
a crowd, they're very good at identifying what
they look like and also where the cameras are.
There's a steer who identifies the good targets.
Tim Ferriss: Pause for one sec. So the shade,
is that a pre-game activity or is
that done real time?
Apollo Robbins: Both.
Tim Ferriss: How do they alert people to an issue?
Apollo Robbins: Well that's often an indicator of
who they are too. A shade might use a physical
indicator. Sometimes as different groups go they
used to use Nextel phones or they used to
— so I've seen that happen at a mall when
I visited DC a number of years ago. I've seen
it happen different ways in Japan with kissing
noises. In Naples, they do whistles, it's
different sounds. Colombian diversion teams
will use a finger up the back of the neck, which
indicates that we have surveillance and split.
They'll do probe testing where maybe as somebody's
going in to do a steal, if they sense they've got
heat from a surveillance, they might drop
their sight line towards a lady's purse. If
someone bounces off their sight line and tracks
to that, they know they've got heat and so they
give a signal to their team to dissipate.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So we stopped at shade,
I interrupted. So what came after shade?
Apollo Robbins: Steer. A steer is somebody
who qualifies the mark. These are right out of
Whiz Mob. As I started meeting different teams,
it's been fascinating to find people on the street
that still use variations of these terms because
that means somehow they learn those from someone.
Tim Ferriss: What does the steer do?
Apollo Robbins: They qualify the mark.
Tim Ferriss: They do a testing
bite and they're like —
Apollo Robbins: Well think
about the cost risk association of if we're going
to make a play on someone, we might go to prison
for it. We need to qualify them more.
Tim Ferriss: Or make sure the juice
is worth the squeeze.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: How do you qualify?
Apollo Robbins: It's changed now with phones,
but if you have earbuds or any kind of cord
going down to a device, I now know where it is
and I can qualify that. So for a lot of Eastern
European teams and in England and other places,
they just know that you're going to have a
phone. So more people become targets just for
their phones. They know how to fence those and
run those in the market. There's clever things
of what they can do with a phone now. They can
run it through your whole bank accounts really
quick now. So it's more than losing your phone.
Tim Ferriss: They can access your
bank account vis-a-vis your phone.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. I don't know exactly this
play because it's not like a zero-day major hack,
not like a sponsored state hack. They do have some
way of getting into your phone pretty quick.
I've seen that over the last three years, take
a surgence of stealing at a nightclub. It could
be as simple as pointing it back at you, get your
facial recognition, but some kind of automation
that they're running to be able to run through all
your accounts, through your passwords, shut you
out, set up dual factor authentication, lock you
out of everything and just take you virtually.
Tim Ferriss: Yikes.
Apollo Robbins: So that's a whole different thing.
Back in the day, once upon a time when the steers
would go, they'd be more interested when you go
to an ATM or a bank and you qualify, they call
it peek in the poke, seeing what money is inside
the wallet. They had names for all these things.
The pit, the kick, the bridge, the fob, uptown,
downtown for different pockets. They all had
names and they could use them around each other.
They had a lot of — it was a very rich language
that has — some of it's permeated into our
culture. It's a fascinating place. The steer,
I think for me, when I'm looking for a team, I
often look for the steer. Either the steer or the
shade. If I'm in a crowd, I'm looking for their
scout because the scout's moving sight lines. He's
looking, I look for people that are either targets
or they're law enforcement and I can identify
those. If I can identify them, somebody else is
looking at them. So then I just track sight lines
through a crowd to see who's looking at them.
Then I'm going to look for their signals and I
can start to identify the group. Then I can
start to look at how they're doing their —
Tim Ferriss: So from a defensive standpoint,
someone's going on a road trip, they're going
to be going through all sorts of countries.
They're going to be in crowded environments
surrounded by lots of people. Chances are there's
going to be, if not solo operators, teams in these
environments. Let's say it's festivals and so on,
where certainly teams are at work, much like the
Kentucky Derby or you go to Carnival, you can bet
your ass there are going to be some pros there.
What can you do? What would your advice be
to someone who doesn't want to get their
stuff taken? I guess I would imagine there's
just don't carry anything you don't need to
carry. There is other preventative measures.
I mean you hear about money belts and this,
that and the other thing. What are your thoughts?
Apollo Robbins: Just like self-defense, it's a
mindset first. Over the last 30 years I guess that
I've been doing this, it's kind of crazy, three
decades, I've seen society lower their situational
awareness and increase their overconfidence.
Tim Ferriss: It's crazy.
Apollo Robbins: It's a
juxtaposition between that. It's the pandemic of
the Dunning-Kruger effect. That it's this level
of unconscious incompetence or this illusion
of invulnerability. There's articles saying
that pickpockets don't really exist anymore,
that that's gone down. I disagree. Pickpockets
aren't the only problem. I just talked about the
hacking element of this. Deep fakes is a whole
new thing. I mean a recent thing that's
just gotten a case with impersonating,
you might have seen this, on a ransom case where
they implied that they ransomed a daughter.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So they
used a deep fake to quote,
unquote, prove that they'd kidnapped someone.
Apollo Robbins: They had the audio of a daughter
talking to a mother screaming that she's been
kidnapped. I mean that's going to drive anybody
to take the behavior right away.
Tim Ferriss: So they were
able to extract the ransom?
Apollo Robbins: I believe so. I know that's
being prosecuted though right now. I think it's
one of the early lessons. There's also weaponized
as far as in the military right now, there was
somebody that impersonated the mayor of Kyiv
within the last three months that was speaking
to other mayors in Europe. It was Russian-based,
but they were on a realtime live Zoom call
while they were talking to these people, and
doing a realtime live deep fake on a Zoom call.
Then a few minutes in there was some kind of
glitch or longer than that, they got enough
information, there was a glitch. Then they
called back to the mayor of Kyiv and they said
he hasn't been on a call. There's a future there
that's coming that is intense. So a lot of
these concepts where I mentioned them from
pickpocketing and things, that's why I noticed I
didn't go to just getting a better money belt. I
went to the importance for concepts. The
overconfidence will work against people.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. You see people in any major
city, we're sitting in New York City right now,
the number of people I have seen see a go
signal and walk across the street with earbuds
in looking at their phones, not checking either
direction in this city is unbelievable. I mean,
hundreds of them. I've seen hundreds.
Apollo Robbins: Two times when I've been to Japan,
the first time I went there, there was this kind
of connection of everybody around. Then the second
time, a couple decades later I went back, the
latching in of the smartphones. It really does
become this kind of, not narcissism, but this
kind of egocentricism of through their virtual
world they're exploring out there. While they're
plugged into that, like the matrix I guess you'd
say, their physical body becomes vulnerable.
So as a predator mindset of looking at people
like that, there used to be a term among thieves
called the grift sense. They felt that the grift
sense was more important than technique. The
ability to extract that from someone and be
able to know where their attention was, how much
they're investing their attention on a thing. Now
it becomes more salient when somebody is holding
their phone and you can see where their attention
is and you can see what they're doing.
Tim Ferriss: So I don't want to beat a
dead horse here, but I am curious. Let's just
say you've tried to identify the minimum of
the essentials that you want to have on you.
You've got a safe at the hotel. Not saying
that's automatically safe by the way, but for
argument's sake, you've tried to leave as much
behind as possible. No cash. You're like, I'll
try to use Apple Pay. You've got your phone,
where should you put it on your body? Some targets
I would imagine some are harder than others.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, they are. So your inside
jacket pocket. They used to think that that was
the hardest pocket to steal from because they
would call it kissing the dog. That was the old
term. Kissing the dog meant that I would have to
see the mark's face. With most other extractions,
you wouldn't get to see me. My team would
lock you up. I would work in a blind spot
angle and I would do an extraction that way. If
I had to steal from inside your jacket pocket,
I've come up with a few ways to extract that
without you having to see my face per se. I can
show you maybe some of that a little bit.
Tim Ferriss: Headbutting the dog.
Apollo Robbins: Yes, headbutting the dog. Make
sure they don't remember. So inside jacket
pocket is a spot. I think it's more of when
you take things out to make a payment, it's
useful to leave something there. There's a great
— a thing that often beats security is what they
call satisfaction of search where they're looking
for a thing, an anomaly. They find something that
satisfies that and they stop looking. You
can reverse that and use that for thieves.
Give them something to find. If you're
going to go make a purchase out somewhere,
quarantine a portion of your money. Any valuables
that you have, sentimental or other things,
don't wear them publicly. If you're moving
into any kind of isolated spot, it's not just
pickpockets, it's for being mugged too. You
can hide them in plain sight. So for example,
what is your EDC? What are the things you carry
with you? Now more and more people are carrying —
Tim Ferriss: Everyday carry?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, EDC,
everyday carry and definitely a pickpocket's
library. Your water bottle, a coffee cup,
those things. If I take things that are of value,
sentimental value, an improvised safe could be a
coffee cup. I put these items inside of a coffee
cup, put a lid on it. Now even if you rob me,
taser me, and strip me down, you probably
won't search in that coffee cup. That's the
mindset that I'm talking about. So the idea of
treating the unimportant as important and the
important as unimportant, you want to simplify it.
I think you can take that to your hotel room. Are
you going to buy some kind of stash concealment
that looks like after shave or you're going to do
those things? Instead of leave something there
in the safe because you need to satiate their
curiosity. You need to give the dog a bone to
find. You need to, as Herb Simon in behavioral
economics, he would call it satisficing. You
need something that satisfies their curiosity.
Tim Ferriss: I'm glad I asked. Thank you.
What is The Illusion of Knowledge Project?
Apollo Robbins: That is a current effort. So we
have a new company that we're trying to create.
I've kind of tiptoed into that as we've been
speaking about because it's a soft business model.
It's still a shape of what the market is for that.
We think it's important to point the finger at the
problem that we see on the horizon. So I'm trying
to find — the benefit is I have an amazing network
of people that I've learned from. It used to
be thieves, but now it's security specialists
and other ones, and just specialists around the
world that are incredible experts in these areas.
I was saying, my background's in entertainment.
We did some TV works, different things. Can we
repackage shows, whether it's TV or live
experience or content that can help people
engage with things that they might not think
should be important, that they might not think are
important, their data, their other things? Can you
reverse a room escape and make it a heist? While
people are trying to break into a thing they learn
about their personal data, these kind of examples.
Tim Ferriss: That's a fun idea.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, it probably
is now stolen that I've said it out loud.
Tim Ferriss: We could add in a bunch of
bleeps if you like.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah,
no, leave it in there. It's just karma for me
doing all the things I've done. It's the kind
of things that give you those ideas. So we did a
project along that, it was a video project called
The Illusion of Knowledge. It's this Daniel
Boorstin quote that "The enemy of knowledge is
not ignorance, it's the illusion of knowledge."
That marries so well with my background growing
up around cons. Since my job has always been
instilling confidence, not just the extraction of
personal items from a person, it's getting people
to make other decisions. As I learn about that, I
think it's very important for people to understand
that we are all puppets. We all have strings.
It's a benefit for people to know that about
themselves instead of saying, "But I'm not a
puppet," and realize that they do have a string
and what does it mean for somebody to pull that
string. That awareness of what it looks like in
different ways that those strings can be pulled,
I think can help bring people so that the flags go
up. So we're creating this project, The Illusion
Knowledge Project, to highlight some of that.
Tim Ferriss: Where can people find that
or can they not yet find it?
Apollo Robbins: They can't find
it yet. There's a trailer. We have this website
called Equivoke. Equivoke is E-Q-U-I-V-O-K-E. Or
they can go to my website. It's easy. My website
is istealstuff.com and it's easier for people to
remember while they're driving. If you go to
that, there'll be a link to Equivoke. There's
a link to those things, explore and poke around.
I don't have much content out there that I put
as products because right now I'm at a phase
where I have two kids. I have one that's 30,
one that's six. I want to try to do the thing
that I can to change the world in the way that
I can. So a lot of these are legacy type things
that build it first, build business model later,
which is probably not the best approach.
It's something that I'm doing right now.
Tim Ferriss: It may not always be the most
failsafe approach, but it is, I think the
approach that I see aligned with intention
and integrity very often in people who are,
and I mean this in the most complimentary sense
possible, high-level craftsmen or craftswomen. And
it's not impossible to do. It can be difficult to
do. But I don't think it's an incorrect approach.
Does that make sense?
Apollo Robbins: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Because you can, conversely
— look, I invest in a lot of, or I have
historically invested in a lot of startups and
early stage companies and so on. And it can be
incredibly profitable to start with a model
and then figure out what fits around that.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: However, when you have a craft and
when you have the refined perception and ability
to operate in the world that you have, that you
can expand into these different domains, I think
that approach makes a lot of sense. I really do.
Because you can corrupt the sincerity of the
knowledge you've accumulated by forcing it —
Apollo Robbins: Into a model.
Tim Ferriss: — into a model. Yeah. Anyway.
Apollo Robbins: Well said. I think, I don't know
if the right metaphor of spoke and hub, but it
is a little bit like that. I have different ways
I've been able to make a very good living through,
whether it's speaking or doing workshops or doing
training or creating things to teach security. And
as I'm doing those, since I got my boxes checked,
I felt, okay, let's be exploratory. What else can
I use this thing that I have, this network that
I have? And instead, can it be something that
is using the fun part of where I came from?
Tim Ferriss: So I have to ask, because this
is just my brain won't let it go.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So the 40 Elephants, I just love
this name. Are there other historical figures
or bands of merry pranksters/criminals who
have particularly memorable names or stories
for you? If you had to put together your
League of Legends, is there a shortlist?
Apollo Robbins: I've had the good fortune
of meeting a lot of interesting characters,
but there's some that I've spent time with
and there's some that I've just read about.
In the space of famous thieves or con artists,
there is the Unsinkable Titanic Thompson who —
Tim Ferriss: Titanic Thompson?
Apollo Robbins: Yep. The nickname was Ti,
from those who knew him well. But there's
books been written about him. I think people
have talked about doing movies over the
years. But supposedly he would advertise
he was coming to a town, because he gambled
on everything and people were drawn to that.
He was a proposition bet hustler. But he had
super skills. He acquired a lot of skills.
Tim Ferriss: What's a proposition bet hustler?
Apollo Robbins: Meaning he bet on things that he
would just win. He had special set of skills or
support staff, covert support staff that allowed
him to make outrageous bets on weird things.
Tim Ferriss: Can you think of an example?
Apollo Robbins: One, he would bet just first
on golf, he's very good at golf. And he would
play somebody and he'd be beating him and
he says, "Listen, I'll give you a handicap,
I'll play with left-handed." And then he would
beat him again and they didn't realize that
he was left-handed, but he is that good
that he could beat people right-handed.
Tim Ferriss: Back to Princess Bride again.
Apollo Robbins: Yes. And so he definitely
could switch the hands, but he was very famous
for being able to throw things accurately inside
of cups from a distance. Other things, he could
throw a card from a long ways away through a
window. And being above a pool hall was one
story where he would be trying to toss a hat,
missing occasionally. And side bets on a poker
game. And he says, "Let's bet a grand that I
can toss a card through that window all the
way down where the window is," and somebody'd
take the bet and throw a card through and then
they'd close down the window, he gets a second
bet. Then Kenny, he says, "Listen, I'm going to
throw it through the window, it's going to come
back, and it's going to stick to the outside
of the window." What? No, just silly. And it
would. And you see those in the literature, but
they're like, "No, that's like magic territory."
And then he would, somebody would be
eating pretzels and he says, "The pretzel,
I'm going to take that pretzel and throw it
over that three-story building over there,
or that wall line." And they'd say, "No, that
can't." And he would and he'd throw a pretzel
over a wall. So he seemed like some kind of Robin
Hood/superhero. But there's great books on him,
the Unsinkable Titanic Thompson. I have the good
fortune of knowing the last surviving member of
his team that was the guy who was down below in
the pool hall with a fan in rubber cement who
painted the window. But he would do amazing things
to layer these very intricate cons besides that.
So there's a handful of those guys. The
Unsinkable Titanic Thompson, Joseph Weil,
the Yellow Kid. Count Victor Lustig, he's the guy
who sold the Eiffel Tower twice. And it's amazing,
how do you sell the Eiffel Tower? And it is
a beautiful con of, he took advantage of the
time when the Eiffel Tower [did not have] the
significant value that it [would]. It was after
World's Fair and it might need to be turned into
scraps. So he put out a bid as a city official
to be able to look for somebody who could tear it
down. And then as different contractors bid on it,
he found a guy who really needed the job.
And meanwhile the wife of the guy says,
"I think there's a rat. I smell something. There's
something up here." And he had the beautiful turn
in a con, which he recognized that the wife had
that suspicion, and he answered in a unique way.
He just said, "Listen, I've got to make something
on this. If you guys really want this deal,
I'm going to need a cut." So they decided,
"Okay, hey, that's the rat." That's the
thing. He is suspicious. He's a city official
who needs a cut," instead of "It's a whole
fake." So not only did he get the money he was
getting, he also got the extra money as well.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, man.
Apollo Robbins: So there's
all these guys, all these interesting lessons of
these guys. But I had a personal best friend for
17 years who — Rod the Hop.
Tim Ferriss: Say again?
Apollo Robbins: Rod the Hop.
Tim Ferriss: The Hop?
Apollo Robbins: Yep. And he is significant. If
people have ever watched Ocean's Eleven and they
wondered, "I wonder if there's a real Ocean."
There's a couple of guys that Ocean's character
would probably be attributed to, but Rod would be
on that shortlist. Among thieves at least. He was
a legend among thieves and people didn't know what
he looked like generally because of the nature
of the work. But he played a lot of different
styles. He was a card hustler, card cheat. But
there's a Southern style, a Gardenia style. These
different styles of playing long and short games
using devices that shoot out your sleeve and grab
things called the Joint or Kepplinger Holdout.
He was very good at a lot of those
things. I met him when I first moved
to Vegas and he offered — he was sitting off
in a corner. It was at a thing where some
magicians were in, he was off the side of that.
And he was playing with plastic cards and he was
shuffling them at the table and not in a way that
magicians handle cards. And he had an edge that
was a little bit more felt like family to me. And
I saddled up to him, talked to him a little bit.
Tim Ferriss: So not the way that magicians
handle cards in the sense that you recognize
more of like a working card mechanic?
Apollo Robbins: Yeah, because mechanics can't
have flourish. They can't pick up the deck off
the table. They don't shuffle in the same way that
they do. All their slides have to be done within
the constraints of what the casinos have manifest.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Apollo Robbins: So it would look
very mundane on the surface, but there's a lot
going on there. And also plastic cards, magicians
would never want to use plastic cards, but poker
players would. So when I began talking to him,
we kind of hit up a friendship and talked a little
bit. And as he learned more about my past and some
of the vibe — I was going through a divorce at the
time too, I was around 21. He knew I needed some
money and he said, "Hey, you want to come play
with my team?" And they were hitting casinos or
at least side spots, kind of periphery casinos
or gas stations and hitting slot machines and
things. And he could cheat a slot machine and make
it pay out a bonus. But he needed watch guards. He
needed me to learn a CODY system and stuff. And
I said, "Sorry man, I've grown up around some
things like this and there's this line that I know
once I step across that line, I'll always move
it. So I can't, man, but I really appreciate it."
He says, "Well, how about all these magic books?
What are you going to do with those?" I said, "I
don't know. I guess I might have to sell them to
get this thing for the divorce." And he said,
"Well, I'll buy those from you." So he bought
all my magic books from me. And one of his team
turned on him and he ended up getting arrested
right after that. And I got this box of books back
with this little note as a friend just saying,
"I knew you wouldn't take the money unless I did
this." He gave me all my books back. So later when
he got out of prison, I said, "I'm doing some new
stuff now and I need some friends. You want to be
a friend?" And I asked him to join our team.
Tim Ferriss: That's a great line.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. So he joined the team
and we had about a dozen guys. Kevin Mitnick,
a famous hacker was one of those guys.
Tim Ferriss: The Art of Deception.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. And he was a dear
friend who just recently passed away.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I didn't know that.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. But I saw
him right before he passed away last year, I mean
right before he got sick last year of cancer. But
very dear friends I've learned so much from.
But Rod used to do heist on casinos. Mitnick
had all of his legends. It's a story for another
time. But I've been influenced by amazing guys
in that way that I've learned about.
Tim Ferriss: So what did the team
do? What was he doing on the team?
Apollo Robbins: So that was definitely,
I can clarify, a bad business model. So that was
Whizmob Incorporated, inspired by the book you
mentioned, Whiz Mob. And the idea was that we
would team guys together and send them out for,
as a speaking agency, for security. Maybe
team them with their counterparts in law
enforcement. Mitnick already had that game
going. He was doing full penetration testing,
so he just hung out with us as a subject matter
expert. It was beneficial to learn what are covert
communication systems that pickpockets use versus
card cheats versus a second-story hacker or guys
that would break into a place like a cat burglar
functionally. So all those kind of guys we had in
our cadre. And they all had different ways of
approaching those things. So it was valuable.
Also him and pulling and tugging at social
engineering, which I considered very similar
to an evolution of con. He had me come in and
speak at DEF CON, his company KnowBe4 later. But
we learned from each other in those worlds.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Well, we've covered a lot
of ground here. Is there anything that we
haven't covered that you'd like to cover?
Is there anything you'd like to share with the
audience? Ask of my audience? Anything at all
before we start to wind to a close?
Apollo Robbins: My daughter's six,
but when she was around three she was learning a
lot of new words that I don't say. And you try to
choose what's a good word and a bad word, and
how often. If you use the word "no" too much,
do they become numb to them? So maybe use other
words besides "no." And I was always interested
in how different experts do parenting and what
that might be. But there was a word she asked me,
"What does boring mean?" Without really thinking
about it too much I said, "It's a word that's not
a bad word, but it's a word I don't use really
because I don't really have it. I've never been
bored." But part of it is because boring means
that your imagination is broken. So you've got
to find a way to do it, you've got to find
something to do, and you've got to use your
imagination better. And I didn't realize what that
would do, but now I have a kid who's never said
that they're bored. And that's a huge thing.
Tim Ferriss: That's huge. What an advantage.
Apollo Robbins: What happens when we just
change a word? What does it do to a behavior?
So in all the long drives she's taken with
us across the country, she's never said,
"I'm bored." She knows what it means, she hears
her friends say it. And she doesn't think of
my dad tells me not to say it, because I tell
her, "You can say it." But she chooses not to.
And it's a thing that I'm obviously proud of her
about that, but it's also to me such a valuable
thing of the state of being bored is where
creative epiphanies often happen. But what
if we just remove that word and think of it in
a different way? And we think about as when she
is in that state, she says, "I need some help. I
need to think of something to do." And she's just
doing that. And I said, "Well, there's so many
things and you only got so much time. Where do
we want to start?" And I said, "Should we go this
way? That way? What?" And it becomes a different
thing. So I said, "Do you want to do something
that you want me to help you generate, come up
with some ideas?" She says, "No, I just want to
think for a little while." So she'll just look out
the window and think. And so it's a fascinating
thing to look at how long her attention
span is compared to a lot of her friends.
Tim Ferriss: Do you think that that has helped
her despite not having, I assume, not having had
the Forrest Gump braces to become a better watcher
in the same way that you became a good watcher?
Apollo Robbins: I think so. I think that is one of
the contributors. Also, I'm a big proponent of — I
used to call it covert learning strategies of the
Miyagi aspect of I'm going to do covert learning
to repackage the hard lessons as something else.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, you want to learn how
to levitate a coin? I think it's in —
Apollo Robbins: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: These three books.
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, you only
read volume one? I think it's in two or three.
Apollo Robbins: And there's two things. Because
if somebody has a big ego and they don't
think that they need to learn something,
or you have learned helplessness where people
don't think it's possible for them to learn it.
So what if I hide that? Another pro-social
application of deception. Maybe I can use
that to help them learn a thing they thought
was irrelevant. And secretly I've taught —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, or impossible.
Apollo Robbins: Yes. And now,
by the way, you can do it. And so I'm
really interested in that space. And we
do that to her all the time that now if she
says — trying to teach her a memory system,
can I repackage as a series of other things that
now this little tour that we took was secretly a
mind palace and now she learns how to do that. So
what are the different ways that you can package —
Tim Ferriss: Trojan Horse.
Apollo Robbins: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: Apollo, what a gift. What an
incredibly fun conversation. I think we
may stand up and try to do some things. So for
people who are interested in some more visual,
you can go to Tim Ferriss on YouTube and we will
hopefully post some goodies there for you. Where
are the best places for people to find you online?
Apollo Robbins: I'm on Facebook, although there
seems to be like five or six of
me that isn't me, as imposters do.
Tim Ferriss: Sort of appropriate.
Apollo Robbins: So I haven't canceled
them out. But there's one me on Facebook. I'm on
Instagram, not very active, but I'll probably be
more. I haven't engaged with the new version of
Twitter. I haven't fully jumped onto the next —
Tim Ferriss: Can't bring myself to say X.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. TikTok, I'm not
coming close to. Just my security
mind won't let me even touch it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, don't do it.
But on Twitter, @ApolloRobbins.
Apollo Robbins: Yeah. So pretty much
@ApolloRobbins across the board.
Tim Ferriss: A lot of my audience, some very,
very interesting folks are on Twitter. So it's
worthwhile mentioning that, just because
that might be fun to see how things come
out of the woodwork. And then as far as
websites go, best website or websites?
Apollo Robbins: Well, they've
funneled through the same thing of
apollorobbins.com or istealstuff.com.
Tim Ferriss: I steal stuff.
Apollo Robbins: They'll take you to the same
place. But this other new one that is going to
be a separate thing is Equivoke. And that one will
be probably a combination of an entertainment blog
with other video content and other things
where we're going to try to point to tools
that are important in this space. There's a guy
that I think is amazing that studies deception,
Simon Henderson. He's from the UK. Him,
Anthony Pratkanis, my wife Ava Do, all them
as a collective, will be doing interviews,
videos, and other things for those guys.
Tim Ferriss: Fun.
Apollo Robbins: So if you want
to come play in the space, learn a little bit
about cons, we won't attack your political
beliefs, but we will attack what you believe.
Tim Ferriss: What a great place to end. Apollo,
thank you for such an incredibly, not just
entertaining but educating and invigorating
conversation. I'm so glad that you made the
time. And for people listening, you can do
more than you may believe you are capable of
doing. So Apollo and I, and hopefully you,
will seek to prove this out. And we'll put links
in the show notes, as always, to everything we
talked about at tim.blog/podcast. And as usual,
I'll say it again. Until next time, please be a
bit kinder than is necessary, not only to others
but also to yourself. And thanks for tuning in.